- Who left this dent on the table?
I would like to know this.
It's been here a while.
- I'm going to say Chris.
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
- And who was the last person
sitting in this point point?
Chris.
- Well, technically it was me.
- We're blaming on Chris.
- I don't know.
- Must have been Chris.
- Yeah.
(upbeat music)
- Hello and welcome back to Trash Taste.
I'm your host for today, Garnt.
And once again with me are the boys.
- That's me.
- This is technically our first
Trash Taste recording
of 2021, even though.
- Oh, you just stated it.
- I know (laughs) I know, I know.
- The matter is ruined.
- The immersion, Gar.
The immersion is ruined.
- People can tell, like,
I like how people are
able to tell the time line
of when Trash Taste recordings happen now
based on Joey's hair.
(Joey laughs)
- Like, because it's
like one week I was like,
oh, he has a lot of hair.
And then the next week is
like, oh, he has no hair.
- It's your hair and my beard.
'Cause like one week I just
decided I'm gonna grow a beard.
And then--
- We are the sun dale of
Trash Taste basically.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
It's like I'm calculating
the shading of Garnt's face.
And I can definitely guess
its sometime around January.
- I like the beard on you,
Garnt. I think it suits you.
- Yeah, I think it looks good.
- I think I did it literally
after a Trash Taste recording.
When I went back after that recording
where we talked about beards and I'm like,
"Sydney, should I grow a beard?"
And Sydney is like, "Just do it, why not?"
And yeah, I kinda like it
now. It's a grown on me.
Pun intended.
I'm already getting the dad jokes now.
- Shave it off right now.
(Garnt laughs)
Jesus.
- But yeah, we've just come back
from our Christmas holidays, which is,
I think this was one of the
first Christmas holidays
that actually felt like
Christmas holiday for me.
Because normally Christmas holidays
are the busiest time of the year for me
because I'm trying to get
like my end of year video out.
And then I don't know
what switched in my mind
to make me realize
what if I just don't do that
and give myself some time off.
But then I put the video
out sometime next month.
- Garnt discovers the word no.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
For the first time, he's like--
- Taking a break.
- Yeah. I can say that now.
- Wait a minute.
You mean the expectations
were just all in my head
and no one really cares if
I just delayed the video
for like a few weeks?
- Never trust anyone. Not even yourself.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- You mean I was my own worst enemy?
- I feel I, one, I'm just
recover from being sick.
So if I'm a little quiet--
- He doesn't have Covid, don't worry guys.
- Yeah. I'm negative boys.
I'm also negative in
life. I'm always negative.
- You just described yourself.
- I'm a negative person.
- I'm just negative.
- What happened?
Like you had like a sore
throat or something?
- Yeah. I had like a
really bad sore throat
and then it just kinda went
and now I'm in the last days
where I still sound sick,
but I feel totally fine.
But just--
- You, you were sipping that
Manuka honey over there though.
- Yeah.
- Do Manuka honey is opious fine.
- It is, it is.
- It just costs an arm and a leg.
- Yeah.
That's the problem, I
remember I saw the other day,
it was like a jar, this
big, of Manuka honey,
maybe like that, it was like 60 bucks.
- What is Manuka honey?
- It's this--
- From a plant, right?
- No, it's a type of
honey made from a certain,
I think species of bee that's
only found in New Zealand.
- I know it's New Zealand.
- Yeah. It's like a Kiwi bee basically.
And it's like halfway between,
I remember 'cause I saw a
whole business insider video
on this.
It's like, yeah, 'cause
they did like a, you know--
- I thought they pollinated
something really specific
like this is the--
- It's probably.
- This is the honey
that it spanked on this.
- I'm sure it's something
like the bee takes the pollen
from a specific plant and
only makes honey out of that
or something like that. But yeah.
I know it's like a Kiwi thing
and the reason is because like
just the whole process of it
is really long and arduous.
And also it's halfway between
Royal jelly and honey, I think
that's how it kind of works. I
don't know. I don't remember.
- I always recommend it.
It's really hard to recommend
'cause people are like,
"You're paying how much
for a jar of honey?"
- Can I not just buy honey?
- No, no, no.
- Just normal honey.
- It doesn't do the same thing.
- Normal peasant, honey bee, honey.
- Peasant like peasant bee.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- When you pour honey, it pours.
The like Manuka honey stuff doesn't pour.
- It's like molasses.
- It literally is like a block.
And I normally like if I scream a bunch
or I'm doing a lot of voice acting,
I'll normally just take
like a little teaspoon.
Not fill it up just like a
little bit. I'll just eat it--
- Yeah. I don't know why,
because there are a lot of
products that are very expensive,
and I'd say that they're
not that much different
from the base product.
Like Manuka, honey versus normal honey.
But Manuka, honey.
I don't know what it is. I
don't know if it is a placebo,
- but--
- It could be placebo.
- It could be a placebo, but
every time I've taken some
it's like my sore throat
just immediately goes away.
- It's that whole thing of like,
are you wearing a product
or are you wearing a brand?
Kind of thing.
When it comes to like
clothes, for example.
- Yo, these bees like
minted by Louis Vulton
like, what's going on there?
- If you look really close
on the side of the body,
it says LV.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- They're like branded with LV.
- Then the bees coming in
with like the drip jacket,
like hello.
- They come to the flower like,
"Hello, I'm here to pollinate you."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Correction, Manuka honey
is not from a specific bee
it's from the Manuka flower.
- Yeah, it is a flower.
- Yeah. So it's a specific
plant they pollinate.
- You confused me, I said plant--
- Sorry, sorry.
- Then Joey came in like
a wrecking ball with bees
and I'm like, hold on. I'm
pretty sure it's a plant.
- Okay. It's the plant
wearing the drip jackets then.
- Should have been more aggressive.
I know Joey, it's a plant.
- I disagree.
- Half this podcast is
that doesn't sound right.
But my, Manuka honey knowledge,
isn't enough to dispute you on that.
- People have Google.
- Yeah. 'Cause I've
tried a bunch of things.
I've tried that really
expensive pink Himalayan salt.
That is the, most of the cost
goes in into mining this salt.
'Cause it's like one of the rarest salts,
one of the hardest salts to mine.
- True, they sell at my supermarket.
They sell at my supermarket.
- Do they actually?
- Yeah, I've got some.
It's probably not real
from it is two bucks.
- It's definitely not
sea with pink dye on it.
- It's probably sea pink diet,
but it says Himalayan salt on it.
Got it for like 150 Yen.
- That ain't right.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
- I actually tried the
second, most expensive,
I think it's the second most,
but it's one of the most
expensive coffee beans
in the world.
Which is how they harvest this coffee bean
is I believe it's like this, the cat poop.
- We've seen the bucket list, Garnt.
We've seen the movie. We know.
- Wait what?
- That's why it became really popular
'cause in the bucket list,
there was this whole big joke
in the movie was the
fact that he didn't know
this expensive coffee
this rich guy was buying
was from pooped out cat.
- Which film was this?
- "The Bucket List" with Morgan
Freeman and Jack Nicholson.
- Oh that one. Okay. I
haven't seen that one.
- I don't know why. I know
that movie, I've never seen it.
- I just know it's that like--
- I thought you were just
talking about a bucket list,
a default bucket list that everyone has.
- "The Bucket List".
- This is why that coffee
became so well known.
- Oh, I've never known that.
Well it was obviously
it was a thing before.
It was a massive part of
the movie was a big joke
that this guy was like, he was like,
"I have to have this coffee."
And he didn't know this whole
time that he was eating like,
cat that was pooping it out.
- It's not actually cats.
It's a kind of like---
- It's like a mountain.
- Like a mountain,
Like a big joke in the movie
is that he's eating the poop beans.
And he's like, and then yeah--
- And Hillarian shoes.
- That's why it became so well known.
That's why everyone knows it, Garnt.
- What I'm more surprised of the fact that
they talk about that in "The Bucket List"
is the fact that you've
seen "The Bucket List".
- What do you mean? It's
it's an amazing fit.
- I don't know, you're the
only one I know who's seen it.
- Jack Dickson and Morgan Freeman.
And you're gonna sit and tell
me you don't wanna watch it.
- It was one of those movies
that I saw like in my,
oh, I'm dating myself here.
I saw at my local
blockbuster back in the day.
- Oh my God, Joey.
- I would say, it was one of those ones
that was always on that
highlighted shelf of like,
these are the talked about movies.
It was always smack bang in the middle.
It was fucking Jack Nicholson,
Morgan Freeman doing that,
like that kind of face.
It just says "The Bucket List".
That looks boring.
- Why did you not watch "The Bucket List"?
- I don't know. It's
just never interested me.
- I didn't even know about it until now.
- It's very good.
- How did they react to it in the movie?
- He was like shocked obviously.
And distraught that he'd
been eating the beans.
- Did he enjoy the coffee?
Was it good coffee?
- No, so he was obsessed with this coffee,
but he didn't know where it was from.
And because Jack Nicholson in the movie
plays a very wealthy man,
he has all the money in the world.
And Morgan Freeman is in the
same hospital room as him
and his has no money.
It's this whole joke of
Morgan Freeman's like,
"Oh, by the way, I found
out about those beans
"that you like so much,
the cats poop them out."
And then it's like, "Haha,
rich man eats poop."
That was it.
- It was the tagline for
the movie, "The Bucket List"
- "Rich man eats poop."
- It's very good.
It it's a very good movie.
I'm not selling you on.
It's really good. It's really good.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Man, "Rich man eats
poop." That's selling me on.
- Connor sells a movie.
So this rich guy eats shit.
(Joey laughs)
- Oh, my God.
- Yeah, I tried it and
it was just, it was--
- Because Sydney gave it to me
and Sydney was making
this massive ceremony
about how it's the biggest
fucking deal on earth.
- I've had it before as well.
And it's a good up of coffee.
- [Garnt] It's a good cup of coffee.
- But is it like to die for? No.
- I'll be honest. I can tell--
- Would I put it on my bucket list?
Probably not.
- I don't know how much Sydney grinded
when she made our cups of coffee.
Because when she made our cups of coffee,
it was like I had three, a
triple espresso or something.
Me and Sydney were just
sitting in our chairs,
being like, "Honey, I know it's Christmas,
"but I think I need to
go out and go for a run.
"I just had so much energy
"that I couldn't even think straight."
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- [Connor] It's poop man.
- It's the poop. It's the poop.
- It's the poop poop.
- It it's the poop. It's the poop poop.
What is it about poop?
Because I was actually
researching this right.
- Well we just to not talk about poop.
Of course Scott somehow brought it up.
- It's Trash Taste.
- It's trash Taste. Of course.
- You were researching poop. Okay.
- Yeah, cause after that I
was researching the coffee.
And that used to be the most
expensive coffee in the world,
I assume because of "The Bucket List".
But now there's a more expensive coffee,
which is based on elephant
poop and it comes from Thailand
and I'm just like, what is it?
What is up with--
- What's stopping me from
ingesting coffee beans,
pooping them out and then just
putting the highest price tag
on it and labeling it.
- The Sea Dog VA espresso.
- The Sea Dog VA expressway.
- I've actually seen
a Japanese YouTube do.
- No.
- Actually no way.
- Yeah. They did it.
- No way.
- It was absolutely disgusting.
No, I'm not gonna describe
the video obviously.
But just, you get a sense of the idea.
- Why? Did he sell it?
- No, you didn't sell it.
He got friends to drink it.
- Got it. Trying to drink it.
You are eating, you're drinking my shit.
- [Joey] You're drinking my shit.
- Your trash tastes special.
- I don't know how that's
on YouTube. It's disgusting.
- Why does YouTube play for different--
- That reminds me of the story I saw
about the reality TV star
that started selling their fats.
(joey laughs)
Did you hear about this?
- Yeah.
- And then she got a heart
attack because of that.
- And then she farted so much
that it gave her gastritis
or stomach problems
that she thought she had a heart attack
and had to go an A$E.
And so--
- [Joey] What an amazing story?
- Yeah. And so after that,
she's just like, you know what?
I should stop selling farts.
So what does she do? She
starts selling farts as NFTs.
- Are you serious?
- [Garnt] I am deadly serious.
- This is a month old news by
the time you're watching this,
but it was very dumb. It was so stupid.
- I'm seeing this and I'm
just like, you know what?
Can we go back to black mirror?
Can we please go back to black mirror?
That is the future that I want.
- All these game companies
as well being like NFTs,
we like them. And it's like, yeah,
'cause you can make money from them.
'Cause you can rip us off.
- Yeah. So sometimes you
just sigh at the future.
Sometimes you--
- Wait, wait. Hold on, hold on. Back up.
How do you, she's selling
her farts as an NFT?
- I don't know how that works.
I don't, you know, I maybe--
- Is she's selling a picture
of her farting into a jar
as an NFT.
- Maybe she farts on the
keyboard and then there's some--
- The fart infuse letter E--
- Yeah, you know how like in the movies,
when there's, someone's typed
in their code on the PC,
you blow the dust on it.
- You see the fingerprint.
- Yeah. Basically what
happens is that she just farts
on the keyboard and whenever
the fart is like traced
on the board, she types out the numbers.
- Maybe she has a fart scanner
where digitizes her farts
into bits and that gets
converted to an NFT,
which can put on the blockchain.
- Here's my fart binary.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- God, I hate the internet
so much right now.
- I mean, they recently,
Japan just made a screen
that you could taste.
- Oh yeah. The likable screen.
- Yeah. The likable screen.
- So it's all concepts.
Mayland's like salivating,
which you like saw that.
- I never wanna lick a screen.
It's like half the good foods
because of the textures.
- Yeah. What I wanna
know is like this screen,
like the screens are like
dirty enough as it is.
And you're telling me that
there's gonna be people
constantly licking the screen.
Are you gonna have to clean
it every time you have
a single leak?
- Have we not learned
anything from this pandemic?
- That is literally the
worst idea in the world.
- Why did you have to announce it now?
- No, I bet George, your
fans would be happy.
- Like, oh my God, I can (laughs)
Finally, I can leave out
my dream of liking sweat.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God. I, I just can't
get over the fart NFT.
It's pretty bad.
- I wonder, I just wanna
know how it works now.
- I don't know.
- I don't know. I thought we had kids.
- Can you Google this actually for us?
- Can you Google fart NFT?
- Yeah.
- How this works please.
- I thought humanity had hit its low
when Belle Delphine was
selling her bath water.
Who knew that that was just the beginning?
She was trying to warn us of the future.
- I think a lot of people
sell their bath water now.
- That was but the Genesis
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
of the apocalypse.
Oh my God.
- Yeah. I'm sure a lot of
people sell bath water now.
I'm sure a lot people--
- Oh yeah, sure.
- No one buys it.
- I'll be honest. I don't
browse only fans so much, so--
- So much (laughs) you
proud as only fans at all.
(laughs)
- Yeah. I don't browse only fans.
So I don't know.
- Garnt has a secret only fans
account but We don't know.
(all laughing)
Just comes out.
- Yeah. I don't know what
people are selling on only fans.
I don't know if I wanna
know what people are selling
on only fans, if this is the
kind of that gets leaked out
to the mainstream media.
- I thought that when I
saw the bath water thing,
I already thought that was ridiculous.
But like, even before that,
there was those places
that were selling, you
ever see those like places
that were selling cans filled with air?
Yeah. Like the, this is a
can filled with Hawaiian air.
And I'm like, really?
How did you get that air?
Did you just go to
Hawaii? Go like that or?
- Yeah, just open the jar.
- Yeah. Just open the jar.
- Well, I guess how is that
different from spring water?
- Spring water makes more sense.
- I can understand why someone
might make an argument.
I don't give a fuck. I'll drink.
- I don't give a fuck.
- I'll put my mouth over the whole tap.
- Get the full essence.
- I want the lime scale of norm.
But I guess some people are
picky. They don't want it,
but normally the whole bottled
water is just like tap water.
They just add like a bunch of
minerals. Yeah. Just add shit.
- Yeah, I mean, you mean minerals?
- I mean minerals.
- Elements.
(laughing)
- I mean elements.
- Not incorrect. Yeah.
- Two shots of lead.
- I mean, it's like beauty products.
Where beauty products, like
they market the story to you
as like, oh, we got this.
We got this product from the
mountains of the Himalayas
where the only freshest tree
grows or something like that.
But it's just someone
in a lab that made it.
And they put, they stuck
a label on it. It's--
- [Joey] Pretty much.
- It's no different.
I haven't done it up my
research on where spring,
where bottled war actually comes from.
- Do you care?
- No, I don't care.
That was a very, noest of nos
- I'm like men, I'm like I will say--
- You can not dismiss
that argument any faster.
Do you care? No.
- I just wanna know.
Did you actually care?
- No.
- Before go down this argument
and start talking about this.
- I Don't care. I'm like.
- I saw those documentaries
where it's like Nestle.
Where they just go into like
towns of America and just take
all their drinking water
and then just sell it
as bottled water. 'cause they
add ,I don't know, like--
- A label to it.
- They add like a one, zero milligram
of chlorine or something.
And then they're like,
now it's treated water.
It's no longer tap water.
- Yeah. But wasn't like a
massive controversy in England
at least was the fact that Dasani.
So Dasani is still in America.
If I remember correctly,
Dasani still in America,
but the reason Dasani is
not sold in England anymore
is 'cause there was
this massive controversy
where Dasani marketed it
as fresh spring water.
But it got found out that
they were just selling bottled
tap water.
- But the tap was coming from
a spring or something anyway.
Yeah. But obviously the
people in the UK are very,
I don't know how to explain it.
Stuff like that really
piss British people off.
The fact that you would
try and sell us something
that is just so basic is
something so much more.
- I'm just wondering if it's spring water,
but it's connected to a
tap and that spring water
is coming out of a tap. Is it spring water
or is it tap water?
- It's a spring, tap water.
It's just taped spring water.
It's whatever you want.
- We've entered the water matter. Right?
- Okay.
- I'm gonna bring you a step
deeper in the water matter.
So onsen culture in Japan.
Are you gonna tell me that
every single onsen water,
is every single onsen we go
to just fresh from the earth
or is it just like, where
does that water come from?
- It's from the ground,
but it's through a tap.
- Yeah it's through a tap.
- So is it hot springs--
- Why are you bringing this up?
or is it just tap water?
- Are you just taking a bath in tap water
like everyone else?
- No, Joey, no.
- Because tap water has
to come from somewhere.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
A spring perhaps.
- I think tap water
implies that it's the grid,
the national system.
Not the thing you're
taking onset bath guys.
- Because I see some onsens
have the water get delivered
to them by trucks. Not tap water.
They get it delivered by trucks.
And I think, well, is
it like, I don't know--
- The onset is, from what
I understand is like,
it's the stuff in the
water, like the minerals
from whatever they dig out of the--
- So there's a clear
difference between an onsen
and a cental, which is a bathhouse.
A cental is just hot water.
There's no minerals in it.
It doesn't have like any of like that,
natural stuff that makes it healthier.
And then an onsen is the
stuff that is mineralized
from the ground, like onsen water.
But I think most people just assume that
oh, bathhouse equals
onsen, which it doesn't.
It's two different things.
- Because I do notice,
depending on the onsen we go to,
the water is very different
depending on where you go.
- Oh yeah. There's like 30 different types
sort of ridiculous onsens.
It's all just different makeup, right?
Like the acid one, I went
with Chris into an acid onsen
and then obviously--
- The one we went to last week.
- Yeah. We went to one last week.
- It was very lovely.
- We could talk about that.
That's a, that's a good segue.
- Amazing segue, Joey. Thank you.
- To talk about the fact
that we just went on holiday.
On a ski trip,
which we've revealed is
not going to be a special.
Unfortunately we do like
to hang out with each other
and not always have to pressure.
- We hang out outside of content.
- Outside of, even though Joey made--
- Made a long matter.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Which may or may not be out by now,
but they'll probably be out by now. Yeah.
But we went to, where
did we go again, Isekoi?
- Isekai.
- Isekai that's a Mongo.
- That's a Mongo. I completely
just, Isekai, that's it.
- Isekai, Yeah in Hokkaido.
- Hokkaido.
- It's like the, one of the
most famously resort in Japan.
Probably like top two.
- Is it the most famous?
Ohakabank and Isekai, the two famous ones.
- Oh yeah. That's true.
- They're two big boys.
- There's Zao in Yamagata.
- That's not that famous though.
- Yeah. Zao is famous in Japan.
- I've also been there and
is like very, very old.
- Yeah. It's not as great.
- Every ski lift is like a plank.
It just like took you.
- Yeah. I mean--
- Hand cranked.
- I would say that this is
my first proper ski trip
because unlike before
I only went for a day
and then I was out of commission
for like every other day.
So I had like day of snowboarding
this time I had basically
like four days of snowboarding,
two like full hard days and
two like kind of like softer
take it easy days,
but still four days of
snowboarding and yeah,
it was a lot of fun.
But my God did my body
hurt the day after. Holy--
- Did your mom ask you how
the white person sport was?
(Joey laughs)
Is that what she asked you
last time or something?
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, she asked me last time.
- How are the white people there?
I will say it was so weird
going into that skier zone.
Just going to that town and
just seeing more people speaking
English than they were Japanese.
- I think I heard less Japanese.
Like I heard more Chinese and
English that I did Japanese.
- Oh yeah.
And that's only gonna increase
once the borders open up.
- Yeah. Yeah. Because like
every single staff member,
not just in the hotel we stayed at,
but just in town for
some reason spoke English
and there are a lot of Aussies there.
- A lot of Aussies. Yeah.
- And if they and speaking English,
then they were basically
speaking Mandarin or Cantonese.
And then you had the very few
people just speaking Japanese,
the Japanese people were
literally in the minority.
From what I could see and
the country's closed off.
So how bad is it gonna be when
the country actually opens up
and tourism comes back in?
- 'Cause I remember
when I worked in HakoBA,
which is the other famous
one in Niigata that is like,
it's like almost 99%--
- Nagano, you mean, Sorry.
- I'm sorry. Nagano, yeah.
Sorry. It's like 99% Australians.
- It's actually scary.
Like I remember some days being there,
like going around to like
restaurants and stuff.
And I would step outside after
restaurant and I'd be like,
oh yeah, I'm in Japan.
'Cause when you're inside the restaurant,
everyone's Australian.
So it feels like I'm
back home in Australia.
- Feels like every country
has their national pests.
Australia has the cane
toads, Japan has Australians.
- Japan has Australians.
(all laughing)
- Localized in the ski resorts.
- Just go. And you're
like, oh yes I can see you.
- So when you're at home--
- Oh my God.
- No. 'cause yeah, it
was super surreal for me
being in a place which
was very clearly Japan,
but all the signs were in English.
The menus were in English
and all the staff members
spoke English as well.
- It was weird, man. It was weird.
- I tried my best speak
Japanese to like anyone I met,
whenever I went to a cashier
or something and anytime I did,
they would just always reply
back in perfect English.
- That's funny. 'Cause when
I was booking the hotel,
I booked the hotel for
Zoe, but I booked it.
I asked like for like a
shuttle service to pick us up.
'Cause it's like two
hours, two hours and a half
from the airport.
- From the airport. Yeah.
- And I was like, well, booking.com says
they have a shuttle service,
I was like, oh great, great.
So I clicked it two days
before they messaged me.
They're like, by the way, we
don't have a shuttle service.
And I like, like what?
What do you mean you don't
have a shuttle service?
They're like, we don't, but
we can help you get one,
just go to these links and get the bus.
And so I go and look for the bus.
There's no seats left on the bus.
I'm like, oh, what do we do?
He's like call up the hotel.
And then I remember, so this
is where I talked the guy
and I'm like oh, is
English okay? In Japanese.
And he's like, in English
he goes, "Oh thank God."
(all laugh)
He was like, "Yeah, that's
great. That's perfect."
I was like, "Yeah, I don't
really like speaking Japanese."
I was like, "Oh great. All right."
He's from the Philippines or something.
And I was like, all right, sick.
And he was like super chill.
He was like, "Yeah. Yeah.
"We'll get you a taxi
mate. You'll be alright."
Very expensive taxi. Oh my God.
You fucked up. We didn't book beforehand.
Like normal people. 'Cause we
booked the trip pretty late
as well. Right? Like two weeks before?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. It was something like that.
It was like quite expensive,
but it was good though.
- It was smack bang in the
middle of the season as well.
So it's probably like the
most amount of people,
but it was really good.
- I will say this was like
probably the coldest weather
I've consistently been in because
throughout my entire life,
the coldest weather I've
really had to deal with is
like minus five, minus six.
- Oh God. Oh God. How did you manage?
- Huh?
- How did you manage?
In my mind when you guys
were telling me to pack
winter clothes, pack
all these different kind
of thermal gear and everything like that.
I'm just like, it's cold.
I get it. I know it's going to be cold.
Nothing in my mind could process
really just how cold it is
up there and just how cold
it feels. Cause to me,
like it gets to minus five
and anything below minus five,
I'm just like, it's cold.
And I'm like, that's I know , it is cold.
That's how my mind processes it.
But my body wasn't prepared
for just the different types
of coldness because it
just never had experienced
that before.
At least not to such a big degree
'cause I've been in Wisconsin in winter
and it gets cold in there,
but we just stay inside all the time.
We're not out there
snowboarding skiing and all.
- So point in perspective,
I think every day on Ridge
was like minus like 10 or 11.
- It was yeah. It was minus
like 16 at the top as well.
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah. It was minus 16.
- At night it shot down even lower.
- Yeah. 'Cause you'd wear like this,
I don't know what you call
it. Not a battle Claver,
but like just like a cloth.
- Like a face mask.
- Well, it's like a piece of cloth
that you put underneath your mask
that blocks here so that
you freeze your face off.
But one of the days it was so cold
that after one run of going down,
like one of the things I tried to touch it
and it was rock solid. It was frozen over.
It was crazy. It was so cool though, man.
It was such a cool ski resort.
- It was, I guess, being in
that kind of cold weather
or being in that kind of cold place,
kind of put things into
perspective for me with,
if you are ill-equipped just
to go outside for a quick walk
or something. You'll probably die.
And I guess I've never
been in an environment
where I've needed to worry
about just having basic gear
to protect myself from the weather.
Otherwise my life would be in danger.
You know what I mean?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah, it gets cold, but it's bearable.
- Yeah, it gets cold, but
just run to nearest combining
or just run to nearest
tescos and just warm up.
You run a bit more, but like--
- The nearest combining
was like 30 minutes.
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
'Cause there was nothing.
And I remember when we
arrived to the hotel,
we got greeted by the receptionist
and everything like that.
And he said, oh, you know,
if you want to go into town,
make sure you book a taxi
because if you don't book a taxi,
every taxi's going to
stop at about midnight.
And they've had some people
that have gone into town,
which is a bit further
away from the ski resorts
and had no way to get
back in like -10 weather.
- It's like a 20 minute drive.
- It's like a 20 minute drive. Yeah.
- It's like a two hour walk in--
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
- The ski resort has a bunch
of different areas around it.
It has a lot of mountains.
We went to this village called Hirafu,
which is technically on
the next mountain over.
And that just puts in a
perspective how far away that is.
- So it just made me think, man.
If we just forgot to call a taxi one day,
we'd just be fucked because
nowhere would be open.
We couldn't get home and we
just have to like survive
outside in the wilderness in
-10 degree weather Celsius,
by the way, Celsius.
- Went to that one bar.
And was he Australian or south African?
- I think it was Australian.
- No, no, no, he was Dutch, I believe.
- Was he really?
- I think his accent--
- Was he Dutch?
- His accent sounded Dutch.
- I thought he had a nosy accent.
- This guy was just like, he
was just like, we were like,
what do we do if we missed the cabs?
- I would know if he was Aussie.
- Okay.
- He definitely wasn't
Aussie. He was European.
- We asked him, what do we
do if we missed the cabs
and the guy's like, ah, just walk come.
- No, no, no. He said, no.
He was like, where are you staying?
And I was like at the, at
XYZ hotel and he's like,
it's walkable.
And I looked at him with Google
maps it was like, walking--
- An hour and 40 minutes.
- An hour and 40 minutes. I'm
like, it's certainly walkable.
Would I do it though?
- In -15 degree weather
is a different question.
- I mean, walk walkable is a technicality.
I can. Yeah. I'm sure
human would be able to walk
from one end to the other.
- I mean, Hokkaid to Tokyo is walkable.
Like you can walk it if you would want to.
- I mean the south pole is walkable.
People have done it.
- If you're Jesus, you can walk anywhere.
- The Pacific is all (laughs)
- It's all walkable.
- Like I have legs.
- It's all about drive.
(all laughing)
- My God.
- This episode sponsored
by Princess Connect!.
- Jesus' Christ, Joey,
you've already taken one life
this year on the Cooking
Special, calm down mate.
- Well, remember when you
two stuffed your mouths for,
with Onigiri last year.
Let me remind you both that
this episode is sponsored
by Princess Connect! and
today's the one year anniversary
of Princess Connect! and to celebrate,
we're gonna be reliving
that good old dead meme
of 2020.
- Eating more Onigiri?
- No, because this is actually cake.
- No way.
- It was cake.
I don't know why I cut it.
You can easily just eat it.
- Just don't mind if I do.
- What flavor have you got?
- I
looked........................................Drum
food.
- Mine's chocolate.
- Chocolate.
- I got cookies and cream.
Well while the boys are
pleasantly eating the cake
this time, let me tell
you about the free stuff
our sponsors at Crunchy
roll Games are giving out
to all of you anime fans out there.
You get free 10 draws every day.
I repeat every day,
free 10 draws until February
the 15th in the game
and double rate ups on
all three star characters
when pulling on the new featured banner.
- That's sweet isn't this cake
commuting right now. Joey?
- The new banner features
Muimi and the Princess Gala.
Plus a bunch of other characters
you don't want to miss out on.
If you've never tried Princess Connect,
this is the best time to check it out
and join over 5 million
others in on the action.
Links in the description below.
Yo, hand me some of that cake.
- Yeah. Might try mine. Try mine.
- Unfortunately you don't get
these delicious Onigiri cakes,
but you might catch your
favorite Princess Connect YFU.
- Thank to Princess Connect
for sponsoring this episode
back to the show.
- This is so nice though.
It is so good. we had like a
really nice onsen in the hotel.
- Yeah. It was one of the
best onsens I've been in.
- Being cold all day and
then just going in the onsen
and the onsen was outside as
well. Yeah, it was so good.
- So you kind of put
yourself in the water,
maybe up to your chest or
the bottom of your shoulders,
you get this perfect blend
of like your bottom half
is nice and warm and toasty
in this mineral water.
And then your top is
just getting covered--
- Such is anime.
- It's so anime.
- It's it's so anime, especially
going in an onsen is anime.
Going in an onsen in snow
is just like, this is--
- Anime a air.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- It's pretty anime.
- 'Cause you are literally sitting there
and you see the anime steam,
where you see the steam
where there are sensors, everything.
That's literally what it was like.
- Yeah. You couldn't see anything.
Like there was just so much steam.
You couldn't see anything.
- Was amazing.
- Yeah. So it's just
like a real life sensor.
And so this view we had
of just the snow as well,
it looked so aesthetic.
It was just unfair.
It looked like a wallpaper.
- It looks like unreal engine fire.
- It literally looked like
an unreal engine test.
- It's a rendering of not real life.
- It looks so good that
it looks unrealistic.
- That's the only part I
regret not being able to walk.
'Cause that was probably
like the most aesthetic part.
- You can't take a camera there.
I can't take a camera.
- It was good. Oh gosh.
- Yeah, fucking dicks out boys.
- Yeah. 'Cause it was
so cold on top there,
as you were just staring at the landscape,
your hair would freeze.
So like our hair was frozen
solid while our bottom halves
were like nice, nice and toasted.
- But it was so weird
because even though your hair
is frozen and your shoulders
and head are just covered
in snow, you're not cold
because you're sitting
in boiling hot water.
- [Garnt] Yeah. You're
sitting in boiling hot water.
- So it's like this
perfect, weird balance.
And it's just, yeah.
- I don't know what
minerals they had going on
in that bath, but like every
day I felt like silky smooth.
I felt amazing.
- Yeah. It was probably just salty.
- Like baby wash.
- Whatever that mineral was--
- You don't drink it, Garnt.
- I know I don't drink it.
I didn't mean to drink it.
- Garnt gets in the onsen and
he's like, yeah, it's kinda.
- I gotta coat my stomach.
- Yeah. He's like the
ice cream testing guy.
- That's a ten.
- He's like, chocolate, out of four.
- Sometimes a bit of
bath water just slips in.
(Connor laughs)
I sound like Mailin now.
Like you guys never
licked bath water before.
- I didn't get near the bath water.
- I don't like how you
used the word slipped in
that implies it's going somewhere else.
- Sometimes you just like
watch your face or whatever.
And you just get a quick taste.
- You don't wash your
face with the onsen water.
- Well, so sometimes like my
face was like freezing cold.
I needed to warm it up.
- No. No. That's what
the towel's for, Garnt.
- Well you get the water
on the towel as well.
- That's true.
- How was your snowboarding gone?
How did--
- It was you.
- Do you think you improved a lot?
- I did think I improved a lot.
- I think Garnt improved. Definitely.
- Like I definitely, my
confidence went way up
from day one to day four.
Having said that, I think I
learned the most on day four.
Because day one, two, and
three, I had one goal, survive.
(Connor and Joey laugh)
- We're talking halo music starts.
(all laugh)
- Objective, survive.
- No, because you go
down some of these slopes
and I was having a chat with Connor
about there are like green slopes,
there are like red slopes, and
there are like black slopes.
But at the end of the
day, it's just a label.
God's not there creating mountains,
being like I'm going to
make this a green slope
and exactly these the
same angles throughout.
I'm just like--
- And the map maker is like, "Yes my Lord,
"I'll write that down."
- He's just like playing
like SimCity with the earth
or whatever, God's not doing that.
You get what you're
given with the mountains
and not every mountain
and not every slope.
Even if it's labeled a green slope,
there are different variations.
There are different variables.
- Some of the red slopes
are actually easier
than the greens.
- I would say. So I would say so.
- Yeah. So if you're not
familiar with snow sports at all
the slopes normally categorized
in colors or diamonds,
wherever you're from--
- Shapes. Yeah.
- Yeah. Normally it's green is easiest
then some also use blue in Europe.
- Oh, okay.
Australia also has blues, I think.
- So in Europe you sometimes see green.
You sometimes don't it depends
on which country you're in.
But is normally blue, red, black,
and in America you have black diamond.
China also uses black diamond as well.
- Yeah. It's red circle.
Sorry. Green circle. Red
square. Black diamond.
- Not that far.
- Yeah.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah. 'Cause in Japan, there's like--
- Green square, black
circle, green circle.
- Green circle.
- 'Cause cause normally the
biggest variation of difficulty
comes in black slopes.
Yeah. 'Cause they're like,
some of them are literally just like--
- They're not treated at all.
- Yeah. Some of them are just awful.
And so that's why there's even
a, normally a bigger scale.
But in Europe it's just all black.
They're like, it's all hot.
- Yeah. You've been skiing blue.
- So on the first day we
just stayed on literally
the baby beginner slope.
It was literally like--
- Garnt did, I didn't.
- Me and Garnt did.
'Cause it was like the warmup slope.
- Yeah. Me, Joey, and Luke
stayed on the beginner slope,
the baby park slope of this ski resort.
And then the next day we're like, okay,
we we're feeling confident now.
We're feeling confident to
actually take the gongler up
to the top of the mountain
and ski down the green slopes.
So there was like no distinction for me
from what was the green slope
and what was a red slope.
We actually followed
Connor and we accidentally
took a red slope.
I couldn't tell the difference at all.
- It was exactly the same.
- Because they were just
like me, fine for my life
to go down the tiniest little slope.
And that's that like, I
couldn't tell the difference
between a few degrees.
- Not to mention, the
weather that day was so shit.
The visibility was like five meters, if--
- Yeah. So this resort
had a beginner slope
and when I say beginner slope,
this is the most beginner
slope I've ever seen.
It is literally like a
flat surface that sometimes
goes to a 1%.
- It's like a one or 2%.
So really, amazing if you're
actually beginners beginner--
- Which Luke was.
- Yeah. Like, so with a
friend who came with us, Luke,
who had never skied in his life.
And it was a good start.
I think he got confident on that.
- Yeah. He did.
- He was like, "Oh, I've
only fallen over once.
"I can go at the top now."
- And so if you wanted
to go do any other slopes
that were kind of difficult,
we had to go all the way to the top.
And that's where it kind of gets,
you don't really have a choice
if some of the difficult or not.
But the day before we went up,
we went up the day before and it was like,
the visibility was awful.
You could maybe see like
five meters ahead of you.
And we go pretty fast
and it's like, just like,
I just hoping I don't find
someone. Cause if I do,
I'm gonna hit someone
and it's like, oh God.
Oh God. It was really sketchy.
It really bad. And then--
- But even the second day,
the visibility was quite shit.
- Yeah. Yeah. So the
first day was a lot worse.
I literally couldn't, maybe I
couldn't see at that camera.
- Oh. Wow.
- Maybe, no, no. Maybe
Ashley, where Ashley is.
That was about where
it starts to get blur.
I couldn't see anything.
But the next day was, it was still bad.
- But not as bad.
- So we went with another friend,
Ohara's a YouTuber who lives
here and then we were, he's--
- And Chris as well.
- Yeah. And Chris too,
Chris as well. All right.
So to give you a gauge
of the skill levels,
I guess, what would you put yourself,
where would you put yourself?
- I Would say it's Ohara,
you, Chris, me, Garnt, Luke.
- Yeah. I've no issue doing
black slopes or whatever.
So me and Ohara cause we were
like the most confident ones
we were like, all right,
I was like, you go in the front,
you like direct them
and I'll go in the back.
And I'll, if they fall over,
I'll help them get back up.
Luckily I'm glad I was there
'cause Luke at one point
lost his ski in like really thick snow.
And when you're in ski boots,
you can't really go up the mountain
if you're not used to it.
If you're like a
beginner, it's really hard
to feel confident running
around in the ski boots.
And I was wearing snowboard
boots. So I was like,
"All right, just wait there,
"I'll go and dig through the snow."
And after like five minutes,
I managed to find this
ski buried in the snow.
It'd gone underneath the snow
slid. So you couldn't even,
there was no sign that
it was ship was there.
So I had to like rummage through
yeah. Eventually found it.
So we went down anyway, but like,
so we took these guys up
and it was just a mess.
'Cause like none of them
could like stand up.
Chris is good at skiing,
but Chris is lazy.
(Garnt laughs)
- I did notice that. I did notice that.
- Chris, Ken, and I reckon
Chris could probably do
a black slope, right?
- Yeah.
- Maybe. If Chris really tried.
Problem is black slopes are really tiring
and take a lot of effort.
Chris doesn't wanna do that.
Like Chris also is like,
he'll do reds, but you
really have to convince him.
You're supposed to do greens.
It's like Chris, you
could do reds so easily.
What are you doing?
- Yeah. Because I remember
like the third or fourth day
he came with me, Garnt,
and Luke on a green slope
'cause that's when we started
to get a little more confident
and he was like, "Yeah, I think
I'll stick on a green too."
And I'm like--
- Fuck off here, get outta here,
you passed the exam go away.
- And he's like skiing past
us with no problem whatsoever
being like, "Come on,
boys, catch up boys."
I'm like fuck off.
(all laughing)
- Cause yeah. So, the second
day we tried to take them down
How long did it take us to get to them?
Okay. So if I went from top
to bottom without stopping
and I went as fast as I could,
I could probably do it
in five minutes. Right?
- Yeah.
- But that's like didn't
do initially fast--
- Well, it probably took
us 30 to 45 Minutes.
- No, it took us like second hour.
- Really?
- It took like the two hours.
- The first time at least.
- Oh. The first time, yeah, yeah.
Because after it I swear we
spent like 15 to 20 minutes
looking for, well you were
looking for Luke's skis.
And then before that as well,
because this was right at the start.
So the visibility was so poor.
I probably would have
a hard time seeing Joey
from where he is sitting.
That's how poor the visibility was.
And this was also
basically my only my second
four-day skiing. So snowboarding.
So I didn't know how to
properly control my board.
And I remember we were trying
to stick close to a group.
We were trying to stick close
to a group and I'm trying like
I'm fighting for life. Just
like see where the group was.
And so before every hill,
we all stop before a hill.
Unfortunately my control of
the board was not good enough
that I knew how to stop yet.
So these guys were stopped
waiting for me and Luke.
And so I come along and I
try to stop and I realized
that I am stopping too late
and I'm sliding down the slope.
So I start shouting out, "Oh
guys, oh, I'm going down.
"I'm just gonna go ahead."
And nobody looked back
and I just start stumbling down
this hill, get halfway down.
And I turn around to see
if anyone's followed,
wait a minute, wait two
minutes, wait five minutes.
It's there's nobody. And I'm
just like, where is everybody?
I am on this slope at the top
of this mountain by myself
and I can't even stop
correctly. So I had to like,
I was like messaging the lion group,
trying to get their attention.
Luckily, I waited long enough
for you guys to come down.
'Cause these guys were waiting
for me this entire time.
- Yeah. They thought
that Garnt was behind us.
- That's how poor the visibility was.
So yeah, we wait just 20 minutes
where you were waiting
for me and I was waiting
for you just because we
couldn't see each other.
- 'Cause I was really worried
'cause the way that this
mountain was laid out
is that basically you
have to do really big Ss
to stay on the easy ones.
And if they took any turn at any point,
they have to go down a black slope.
- It's just a cliff.
- And I was like, they're gonna die
if they go down a black slope.
So I was like, I gotta
do my best to make sure,
we got I'm like, like what
are they, what are they,
what are the sheep dogs like
turn around up all the sheep.
I'm like, come on, boys,
let's stick together.
- Yeah. It was kind of like that.
So which is why I think I
learned the most on the last day,
because on the last day we
just found like this one slope
that was perfect for beginners
and had like a ski lift,
take us back up.
And you just had like the
freedom to just do what you want
without worry about dying
or just breaking bones.
- Also the weather was
absolutely gorgeous.
- [Garnt] And the weather was like--
- Yeah. So we had three
days of God, awful weather.
Really bad weather.
And finally the last day we
were leaving, it was amazing.
And it was a shame really.
'Cause the next few days after
that were also really good.
So we kind of booked it the wrong time,
but it was amazing
weather, really good stuff
on the last day.
- I'm really, really impressed
that nobody got injured.
'Cause there's six of us.
I mean, did you guys take
any bad tumbles during--
- Yeah.
- the ski trip?
I let's just say I'm really
glad I rented outta a helmet.
'Cause I think about 80%
of my falls involved me,
just my head, just getting whiplash back.
- Did you like kill a toddler Garnt?
- I almost did.
Because like on the first
like two, three days,
I didn't know how to stop.
So my technique for stopping
involved falling over
and if I didn't fall over,
I would just basically just take out
whoever like was in front of me.
- There's this great photo that
Luke took of you just like,
there's this kid right here
and then there's just Garnt,
menacingly behind me. Like
I'm about to destroy you.
- Move out of the way.
- So I must have decked
at least like three kids
on the display from like
the past three days.
- Oh my God, Garnt the kid killer.
- Thank God no one got injured
except for those three kids.
- None of us got injured.
'Cause it was like a
competition because me and Luke
just kept crashing into each
other on the first two days.
'Cause we had zero control.
We didn't know how to control our boards.
And I remember Luke decked Joey, once.
- Luke legs kicked me.
- I had a great POV of this.
I was like leading everyone
down the right slopes.
And then I was waiting for
them bottom and I saw Joey
just slowly like going down like this.
And then out of nowhere, RKO,
I just see our friend Luke
who doesn't know how to stop.
- He's coming, coming and I
see Jerry. So, and I'm like,
I'm about getting my popcorn
now waiting for this to happen.
Joey's going, Joey's going,
doesn't move his head at all.
And then suddenly he just goes, boom.
Right in the back of his legs.
And Joey just flips over.
Like that was so funny.
- Because all I heard 'cause
I was slowly going down
because it was kind of a narrow stretch.
And also I was waiting for Luke.
So I was slow going down
'cause I saw you guys there.
And I remember specifically behind me,
I could hear Luke in the distance going,
"Sorry, sorry, sorry. Sorry."
It's just getting louder
and louder and louder.
But I thought he was
saying that to other people
that were behind me.
So I was like, oh Luke, silly him.
- Silly him.
- It gets louder. Sorry, sorry. Sorry.
And then just bam right
in the back of my knees.
- Let get fully over.
- I should have been more
concerned, but it was so funny.
- I wish you had filmed that.
- By the time I realized it was happening,
it was like five seconds.
Couldn't have got my phone
out, but I wish I did.
- I wanted to see your POV of that.
- I wish I had my GoPro on permanently.
- I was too busy with falling
over myself to really see
what everyone else was falling over.
'Cause I remember I had a few bad tumbles
where actually some of the worst tumbles
was when I was just actually
not going the fastest.
It was like, cause when you go
fast, sometimes like you saw,
you guys saw me do have
some pretty big falls
where I did a triple back
flip or whatever or whatever.
But to me, those falls are fine.
'Cause you take the momentum
and then you just literally roll with it.
And you hardly feel it.
Some of the worst falls I had
was on like the second day.
- Think I saw this one.
- These guys were trying to
warn me not to stop myself
with my hands.
Because sometimes if you have a bad fall,
you stop yourself with your hands, you--
- You snap your wrist.
you could snap your wrist
or break your or something.
So they were telling me,
you gotta fall on your arms.
You gotta do this.
Make sure you don't try to catch yourself.
You gotta do this. And
like, like this, right?
And I took that as I'm going to do this.
Not realizing the mistake
I was about to encounter
because what happened is I
was taking a bunch of tumbles.
I was like, this doesn't hurt.
I'm a pro at falling
over with a snowboard.
So this one time I was going
down, this really like this,
the slope wasn't steep at all.
I was going pretty slowly,
but I just catched the
edge and I'm about to fall
straight to my face. So
I do what they tell me.
And I tuck my arms in.
Unfortunately my fists were
right front of my face.
So what happens is I fall on
my arm and I just deck myself
in the face.
I just go, which, and
I remember I fall over
and when you have a bad fall
and you just gotta lay there.
I just question life for a bit.
- That's when you know it's bad.
- And I remember I lay
there for a few seconds
and I just hear kind of
going, "All right, Garnt."
(laughing)
- 'Cause I just saw this, like,
'cause obviously it looks
like ants in the background.
I just saw Garnt just fall on his face.
And I was like, get back up, Garnt,
get back up, get back up.
And then he didn't get
up and I'm like, oh no,
he hurt himself.
- There was a couple
times on the last day,
I think where you did that?
Like triple back flip, right?
I saw it in the distance and I was like,
oh, that looked like it hurt.
And then Garnt just didn't
move for about 20 seconds.
I was like, oh he's dead.
Oh he's straight up dead.
- Yeah. I ever seen that one.
I just saw like someone doing like flips
but not the good type of flips.
- I could hear the SSX music playing
when that was happening.
It's like, let's drink.
(all laughing)
- You took so many falls.
- I Did. I did.
I think that's when I
learned the most though.
when you do take the falls.
- It's not about how many
times you get hit down.
It's how many times you get back out.
- It's that drive.
- Yeah. It's about the drive.
- It's actually like the most embarrassing
fall I took wasn't even on the slopes.
It was on the ski lift.
Oh, oh yeah.
- Yeah, because, well, Joey
was there because me and Joey
were trying to get on
the ski lift together.
- Like two man ski lift.
- It was a two man ski lift.
So me and Joey line up together.
So we are just gonna have a nice chill
right up on the mountain.
And so I look back,
I've done the ski lift
for a bunch of times.
So I'm not even a beginner anymore.
I like know how to get on the ski lift.
- It is a lot hard on a
snowboard than a ski is.
- Yeah.
- Also I thought, because I just,
so I'm standing there
waiting for the ski lift
to come around.
I look back and in my
mind I take a mental note
of the momentum of this ski lift.
So I know how fast this thing's going.
And so right before it gets near us
I turn around thinking it's
gonna have the same momentum,
not thinking that they're
gonna slow it down for us.
So what I do is I turn
around and I just sit
and that feeling where you
take a step where you think
there's like a stare and
then there's just not?
So I had that feeling where I sit down
and I just feel nothing.
And I'm like, oh no.
And like, I just, I just collapsed.
And then the next thing I
notice is I feel like the bump
on the back of my helmet,
which thank God I was wearing
a helmet at this point.
And so I'm just like, they're
gonna stop the ski lift.
So my instinct is just to
adopt the fetal position
while they hopefully stop the ski lift.
Plot twist, they don't stop the ski lift.
And so the ski lift just
goes over me and Joey,
just like Joey, I guess
just snowboards over me.
'Cause I look up,
I look up thinking what has
happened and I just see Joey,
just looking back on the
ski lift and being like,
you're right, dick head?
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Well, no, it was, 'cause it was amazing.
'Cause like--
- I'm surprised they didn't stop it.
They should have stopped it.
- 'Cause how I usually do it
with like skis or snowboards
is I wait for the chair to
physically hit me in the back
of the knees.
So that's where I know.
Oh it's right underneath.
- Kinda like bend over. Yeah.
Just get my butt ready.
- I was doing that.
I was looking back, just waiting, waiting,
waiting, waiting until
it hits me right here.
And then I look over, look up, sit down,
thinking it's all good.
And then I hear like this
horrible scraping sound
from somewhere.
I was like, what's what's going on?
I look over and Garnt is just
down there under the thing,
just like this and I was like,
oh, they're gonna stop it.
They don't stop it.
It goes right over Garnt. I was like--
- That's cruel.
- Oh yeah. And finally stop
it after it's gone past you.
And the woman comes over
being like, "You all right?"
I'm like, what do you mean you all right?
You should have stopped it.
Why did you check up on him
after you let the chair go?
- It's like watching a
fight with the teachers.
Like watching the kids,
like when it's over like,
oh you guys are alright?
- It's like, I'll wait
for them to throw a few--
- Yeah. Break it up. Break it up.
- And they break it up there.
- But no, that was the
most embarrassing one.
'Cause they were just like,
everyone was just obviously staring at me.
I stopped the entire ski
lift and yeah, that was just,
just like social anxiety
up through the roof.
'Cause I'm like--
- It happens man.
- Yeah. I know it happens.
- The can't see your face.
- Yeah, that's true.
- You're completely covered up.
- Yeah. Who cares?
- Yeah. Aside from that,
I had a wonderful time.
My body hurt a lot, but it was worth it.
I'm just wearing, I'm raring
to go again. Honestly.
- It's probably like some of
the best snow ever snowboarders
or skied on my life. It was amazing.
How's it compared to like
European ski resorts?
- I think I like European ones more.
There's normally they're normally bigger
way more like options, but I
mean it was the quality of snow
wasn't same. It was so good.
- It's powdered snowed like
so two meters and dales on it.
- Yeah. So most of the black
slopes weren't like groomed.
So we went on one and it
was literally just like,
- it was like--
- Meters.
- on a cloud. Yeah.
And I fell over on one of them.
'Cause it was just too deep
and it was so hard to turn
and it was really bad cause
I basically just shoveled
a ton of no into my jacket and pants.
- Oh. No.
- And I was freezing and
I was like in the cold
with my hand trying to scoop this out.
Mine is 15 trying to get all the snow.
'Cause if you just leave it in,
it'll just melt and then it'll be wet.
And it's even worse.
- That's the worst.
- Trying to get it out. I'm like,
and then I had to ski for another hour.
My ass was completely numb.
I couldn't feel anything.
It was so bad. And when
I got back to the room,
I was like, I can't feel my ass.
It's been numb for like a good two hours.
If someone could have smacked
my ass I wouldn't have known.
- That clip is definitely
gonna be taken out.
- I can't feel my ass.
- I just took such a beating.
- It's so numb.
- Doing too much riding on the board.
It's so good though. It was really cool.
It was really good ski. I wanna go back.
- There was fantastic snow.
- Pain in the ass to get to, but good.
Yeah. I think if I go there again,
I'd probably wanna like go to
Sapora for a bit or something.
And then go there.
- I think that's what a lot of tourist do
is they're kind of maybe
dedicate like a week or two
for the whole thing, because
it is kind of out of the way,
especially if you're coming from Tokyo.
- Sapora is a really fun city.
- Yah, Sapora is great city.
- Sapora is a really chill city.
- Like all I wanted to do
on the ski trip was just
get the basics down for my snowboarding.
And I think I managed to do that.
So now I'm like more confident--
- Proud of you, Garnt.
- Thank you.
- Came along very well.
- You improved a lot.
- But now I'm just ready to
tear it down with the boys
for real hopefully.
And try and keep up with them.
- The real SSX tricky.
- I want everyone to get better.
So that then Chris feels
obliged to do well,
but he has no choice
'cause no one wants to do greens anymore.
- I Mean we accidentally went down a reds.
- On our second day like we just said.
- Didn't go amazing. But we made it down.
Didn't go amazing. But we survived.
That's the important thing we--
- Yeah, basically there was
this tiny and little sign
that was like, go this
way if you want to go back
to where you came from on a green.
And if you go down straight,
which is like the whole thing,
it's really hard to see this thing.
'Cause it also goes back in on itself.
So the slope goes down this way
and there's a little cutoff
here where it goes down and back
around and then joins off
to like another mountain.
- It's impossible to see considering--.
- And the conditions, are really bad.
- Entire thing is white.
- The conditions are really bad.
- So just everything just blends in.
- And then I was last
'cause I was making sure
everyone was alright.
And then was like, oh no,
the Luke who I was with at the time.
'Cause I'm pretty sure he was last.
He went down the red
and I was like, oh shit.
(Garnt laughs)
- Moments before a disaster.
- He just like went down the red.
And I was like, and then
I'm like, oh my God,
they've all gone down the green.
And then we're stuck here.
And it's like lunchtime.
And we was already at, it was like 1:30.
And I was like, oh, we probably
would be eating by now.
Like we're fucked 'cause we wanna go meet,
have lunch with them as
well. So how do we get back?
Like, but then luckily
all these idiots went
down the red as well.
- Turns out we all missed it.
- So we all met up.
But then this scream was
really annoying as well.
'Cause it was like a
flat, really, really flat.
And I told the guys, I was like,
"Guys, you gotta make sure you
get as much speed as you can
"on your snowboards. We're
not walking anywhere."
- We're like, got it.
Put snowboards on two seconds
later. Falls on our ass.
All right. Taking it off now
I'm walking the whole way.
- So I'm going as fast as I can.
I'm getting load to the
ground, get aerodynamics.
I get over there and I'm like,
"Oh my God, I made it all right. Nice."
I'm waiting. I'm like,
they'll come any second now.
Like 10 minutes later, they
come around the corner walking
and I was like, what is this?
- Okay. To be fair, we
did attempt to snowboard,
to me it wasn't a case
of getting to the end.
To me it was a case of how far
can I get before I fall over?
'Cause I knew once I
fell over, that was it.
Momentum was gone. I
gotta take off my boots.
- It is hard to go fast on the snowboards.
- Much easier on skis.
- I don't know. I'm all
self-taught with it.
So I just kind get a
feeling for it I guess.
- Oh yeah. Sure. By the
end of the week we all,
I think definitely got a feeling for it.
- Go fast.
- [Garnt] Go fast.
We were going hell of a
lot fast on the last day
compared to the first day. That's true.
- That's true.
Like Garnt was, can
blitzing down this mountain.
And I was like, oh God, he's
about to SSX tricky right now.
I could feel it.
- Yeah. Well we had to get
back to like our ski resort
and they closed the way of getting over.
What would you call
the, what's the bridge?
- Ski lift--
- What's the, it's like a pathway.
There's a word for this right?
- A pathway.
No, not a pathway.
- Slalom.
- There's a, oh, I forgot the word.
I forgot what it was.
- There's a word for like an entrance.
That is like a, I don't
know. I wish I had it.
- An entry way.
- You're literally using
all the words I would use.
- So there's a path and
it closes at like 3:30.
So I was like, okay. If you
don't go back over as well,
you have to get like a
30, 40 minute bus ride.
And I'd rather kill myself than get a bus.
It's just so depressing when
you got all your ski gear.
And you gotta sit on this bus.
It's like, oh no, why would I
do that when I can ski back?
So me and Ohara were gonna go back over
and then we asked the guys
like, "Are you guys coming?"
And they were like,
"No, we'll get the bus."
'Cause it was like kind of tough.
We had to ski a bunch
quickly, get on a chairlift,
ski over, then walk over
and then ski back down.
It is kind of difficult,
especially if you're tired.
And then they weren't doing
it. And I was like, no worries.
We'll do it. We'll do it.
So we were going and then right before
we were about to cross it, they called us
and they were like, "Oh yeah,
actually we we'll do it.
"I think we can do it."
And I'm like, oh shit. It's
like mission impossible now.
Gotta get these boys back over safely.
Felt like Saving private
Ryan back to the hotel.
We gotta get them back over.
So we had to quickly like rush these guys.
And we were like, no fall,
like, just go don't don't stop.
- Just be good.
- Yeah. Cause they shut it
off at 3:30 for some reason.
I don't know why.
- It's cause at 3:30, the sun sets.
So you just can't see
anything, especially up there.
Like even during the day,
the visibility was so bad.
- It was pretty bad.
- Yeah. I definitely
understand why people wore snow
and ski board from this trip though.
Especially on the last day
where the visibility was clear
and I just kind of realized, oh,
snowboarding and skiing is
just hiking, but the fun part.
'Cause you don't--
- You're going down.
- Yeah. you get like the amazing view,
but you don't have to put in the effort
of getting that amazing view.
- Isn't it crazy when you
like you're on the ground
and you look up at the
mountain and you see as steep,
some of these things are.
And you're like, I skied down there.
I snowboard down there. It's crazy.
- Yeah, 'cause I remember on the first day
when we stayed on the beginner slope.
So the beginner slope had
this ski lift to take us up
the beginner slope and taking
us up because it was so slow,
It took us like what? 15 minutes I think.
10, 15 minutes.
So in my mind I'm like, oh,
we're going up like half
the mountain. Holy fuck.
And then I remember on the
second day when Connor was like,
"Oh yeah, we're gonna go to
the top of the mountain today."
And I'm like, cool.
Where was the beginner slope?
And he points this point,
which is like a 10th of the way
up the mountain.
And you're like, what?
You mean we were this low.
- [Joey] But the view was so good from--
- The view was already
amazing. What's going on?
(laughs)
10 out of 10 would
recommend skiing to anyone
who like me as a kid,
weren't wasn't able to go.
And if especially you're from
a Southeast Asian country.
- Garnt is a white man. Now.
- Unfortunately it just happens
to be the most expensive
vacation sport you can do, unfortunately.
But it is good. It is really good.
You can do budget once.
There's plenty of budget
packages that I know
that we used to do when I was like a kid.
- Yeah. Japan definitely
has those as well, for sure.
- We got like the all inclusive thing.
- [Garnt] I need a PS code.
- This episode is sponsored by Honey.
We all shop online and we've
all seen that promo code field
taunt us at the checkout. Thanks to honey,
manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past.
Honey is the free browser
extension that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies
the best one it finds
to your cart.
Honey supports over 30,000 online stores
from games to fashion brands
and even food delivery.
But Connor, how does it work?
Well, imagine you're shopping
on one of your favorite sites
and then when you get to the checkout,
you'll see the Honey button
drops down on the site.
And then all you have to
do is click apply coupons,
wait for Honey to go through
all of the coupons that it know
for that website. And if it works,
you'll be watching the prices drop
and your savings increase.
Recently, I buy a bunch of camera gear
and luckily Honey saved
me $20 on a big purchase.
Honey has found it's
over 17 million members,
2 billion worth of savings.
So if you don't already have Honey,
you could be straight up
missing out on free savings.
It's literally free and
installs in a few seconds.
And by getting it, you'll
be doing yourself aside
and supporting us, the boys.
So what are you waiting for?
Get honey for free at
joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
- Did you guys get up to
anything else on your holidays?
How was your Christmas.
- Christmas?
- How was your new years?
- Well, it was supposed
to be in Australia.
- Well, that's exactly why
we went on the ski trip.
- Because of--
- Yeah, that didn't happen.
- Like we've been trying to
plan a ski trip for two years
and what it took to take us
to finally plan the ski trip
was a global pandemic to
cancel all our plans once again
to be like, well guys,
I know you guys are free
this weekend.
Or I know you guys are
finally free this week.
Let's go on a ski trip.
Hopefully we'll go on another ski trip
that won't take as much
time or if we plan.
- Two years later.
- Yeah. My Christmas
and news was very chill.
Just spent it with some mates,
played a lot of Mahjong.
- Played a lot of Mahjong?
- I played a lot of Mahjong played.
- Played a lot of TFT.
- Of course you did. Of course you did.
Is that your new apex?
- Yeah. I played with
Darius and Emily a bunch.
So I was like addicted to it. It's fun.
It's fun. I don't know.
It's like NFTs, but you--
- You can leave.
- I've never understood TFT.
- It's auto chess. Isn't it?
- What does that mean?
- I don't know. I it's hard to explain.
'Cause like it doesn't--
- Something like the blockchain?
- Yeah. It's not the blockchain.
It's a game that you
can't easily describe.
I don't know how you describe it.
- Kinda like the blockchain.
- Maybe if Garnt played it,
Garnt's really good at giving
short descriptions to staff.
I've noticed. I am not.
- That's why it's my job.
That's literally what I do for my channel.
- He does that with animations.
- I'm not, when I play
this game, it's like, well,
it's like a battle
simulation, chess thing.
You buy units and then you place them.
And then it plays out
on its own the battle.
- So it's like tower defense, but chess.
- But it's one battle
and then you lose health
or health depend on
what happens. And then--
- But Tower Defense is kinda like that.
You buy units and then
it plays automatically.
- But you're playing
against another player.
So he's buying stuff
and you are buying stuff
and you're placing them on the board.
And then you go against each
other and then you have to,
you also get like stuff that comes up
and you it's like gambling, but like,
there's re-rolling for more
choices to it's gambling.
Do you call it management?
- Gotcha.
- It is a very board boring
game when you explain it,
extremely so.
- [Director] You have to
exactly play it to actually--
- Right.
- It's fun though.
- You say that about most things.
It's one of those games again,
I wouldn't recommend playing it alone.
There's, with friends it's great.
I think with friends it's really fun.
There's a lot of way. It's like chill,
'cause it's not too intense.
Like you can talk, league
is too intense. I feel.
- League, I've tried playing
league with mates before
and I'm just that silent guy
because I'm concentrating
too much on the gameplay
to be able to communicate with my friends
or like have a good time.
- It's great. There's a
lot of downtime in the game
where you are not doing
anything so you can just chat
and it's you can do it very
casually. It's really chill.
It's fun game. Recommend it.
- Okay. I also have been trying to game.
I've been trying to, can I
sound anymore boomer, but no,
I've been trying to
find a game to get into
still kind of looking
started Pokemon recently,
the newest Pokemon and the switch.
- Diamond and Pokemon.
- The first Pokemon ever, right?
Is it your first Pokemon game ever?
- It's not my first Pokemon game ever.
It's my first Pokemon.
Since Pokemon Ruby.
The original Pokemon Ruby on the--
- Like it.
- I don't know. When
does Pokemon get good?
I forgot to.
- That means you're playing it wrong.
- No, no, no. That means
he's not enjoying it.
- I'm not really enjoying it.
I'll be honest because
I've done the first two,
like gyms now for Pokemon
Diamond. And I'm just like,
I remember being, huh?
- That's it.
- Oh, well that's so far.
- To be fair. That's how far I got--
- That's like 10 minutes.
- It's like two hours. Two, three hours.
- Two hours?
- Yeah.
Is it really?
- It's maybe like an hour.
There's a lot of dialogue
you have to sift through.
- There is a lot of dialogue,
a lot of like 'cause okay.
Here's the thing. When
you go to a new town,
do you talk to everyone?
- No.
- Okay. I talk to everyone.
I'm like, okay, this--
- He's a classic JRPG player right there.
- This is me. This is JRP training.
- Being like, I have to
talk to everyone and about--
- You can't miss the items right.
- About an hour in I'm just
like, this is really boring.
- Why are you talking to everyone?
Every so often they give me an item.
So I must talk to everyone.
Otherwise I'm not going
to get all the items.
- What do they give you? A portion?
- Yeah.
- Five, 500--
- Sometimes they give me a super potion.
- Oh. - It's like 500 Pokemon.
- How many super potions do you use?
- I don't know.
- 'Cause your Pokemon's so OP.
- That's not the point.
I've like not needed to
change my Pokemon once
since my main Pokemon.
Yeah. I don't know maybe
my experience is different
from my experience as a
childhood, because as a child,
it was just so easy for me to
immerse myself into a game.
- This is why Pokemon
challenges are so good
and they've gotten, that's why
people love them on YouTube.
It's a way to turn a Pokemon
game into a more challenging
and I suppose adult kind of challenge.
- Yeah, it's way more fun.
I can't play Pokemon Vanilla anymore.
I have to make it a chance.
- That's lots of fun. Randomizes are fun.
- 'Cause I came into this thinking.
I haven't played Pokemon
since Pokemon Ruby.
I can just play this casually
and have kind of the same experience did
as I did as a kid.
And I don't know if I'm just
not far enough into the game
yet, but I mean, to me like
two, three hours into a game
is like mostly of the time.
That's what I give a game
before I'm just like,
do I stick with this
game and fully commit?
Or do I try another game?
- I don't think you like the game, Garnt.
- Maybe, maybe I don't. Maybe I don't.
- Maybe you should try
Nuzlocke version of it.
That'd be more fun.
- What's Nuzlocke again?
- Nuzlocke is like PERMA death basically.
- Oh, okay.
So if you Pokemon fate, you die,
it "dies" and you have to release it.
- And you can only catch
one Pokemon in one area.
- There's lots of different rules.
- It's really good.
- There's lots of local rules as well.
You can kind of mix it up with
like different other rules
and stuff like.
- But why wouldn't you just,
if your Pokemon's gonna die,
why wouldn't you just
like grind like crazy?
- Well, I mean some people do,
but then there's a
challenge element of like,
do I want to grind for 50 hours
or do I just wanna like
gamble and go for it?
- A lot of the time, people
aren't willing to grind
for 20 hours just to secure that Pokemon,
but it's more fun and on
stream it's very good.
It's very good stream.
- It sounds like great stream content.
That just sounds stressful to me.
- It is stressful.
- Nuzlocke is a hell stressful.
- I saw someone do a one PP challenge.
- What's that.
- This great name where every Pokemon
they're only allowed to use the move once.
- Oh, shit.
- In one battle I think.
- Unless it heals up again, right?
- Yeah.
There's there's some
pretty obscure challenges.
- Some pretty good ones.
And there's the soul link,
which looks really good.
Especially like where you both
of you do a Nuzlocke together
and like if Joey's Pokemon dies,
when we caught it at the same
time, my Pokemon dies too.
- Yeah.
- Do you think Pokemon should
have a difficulty setting?
- I think they should just, well,
I don't know why they haven't
had their own Nuzlocke
into the game. Just call it
whatever they wanna call it.
They'll remove the name
Nuzlocke 'cause it's Pokemon.
They won't give credit to anyone.
But I don't know why they
haven't put it in the game.
People do it.
- Because it's at the end of the day,
it's still a children's game.
- But like people are doing
this to their games anyway.
And people are gonna do it.
Why not just add the option?
Like it's not that it's a
children's game, it's like,
but like surely adding like the,
especially like a randomizer.
Surely that's easy to add.
- Oh yeah. It's hell easy.
- Just go in the code.
Be like random all and
then it should work.
- Super easy.
- I know 'cause like for me
I never got the Pokemon
conversation before.
'Cause I just hadn't played
a Pokemon in so long.
But now that I've started to play,
I'm just like, when does this get fun?
How long do I not need to be on autopilot
for before this gets--
- It's 'cause you're playing normally.
I think if you tried a
Nuzlocke on a stream,
you'd enjoy it a lot.
- But if I'm not supposed
to play it normally
as a casual play who
knows zero about Pokemon--
- It's you're old for that.
- Am I too old for that, Connor?
- You've played too many
games. You know how to game.
- I'm not even a gamer.
I'm not even a gamer.
- You've played JRPGs, right?
- Yeah. I've played.
- You still grinding for
like 15 hours to get one sash
or something. I don't know.
You're too good.
- Clearly, not a JRPG player.
- You are too at grinding.
But, and Pokemon now actually
doesn't require any grinding.
You can just do it. Like
you start Pokemon on stomps.
- When did that happen?
I remember in the
original Pokemon as a kid,
I had to like grind the
out of even just first two,
first few gym leaders.
- It lets me share that's so broken.
When did they add that?
- This is such like a funny conversation.
I think they added that
at like X and Y I think.
- No, it was before that.
- Really black and white.
No black and white.
They didn't have it. I
think it was X and Y.
- It was always an item,
but it always only gave it to one Pokemon.
And then now they just, they were like,
just turn it on for everyone.
- You get experience by
catching Pokemon as well.
Which was never a thing.
- Yeah. You get experience
by catching Pokemon.
When you catch a Pokemon,
all the Pokemon in your party
get experience from you.
- What?
- As if you defeated it.
- They're just Oprah
Winfreying the experience.
They're just like you getting experience,
you getting the experience.
- That's sweet.
- As a Gaer gamer, I'm disgusted
by the lack of grinding
I need to do in this game.
- As a gamer, I'm disgusted
by your Gaer game.
- I have been thinking
to do maybe shiny runs
or stuff like that where it's
a little more challenging.
A really fun one I did was,
I did a Pokemon Emerald mode
where, and whenever you enter a building,
it teleports you to a
random part of the map.
- Oh yeah. I've seen that one.
- That one was really fun,
but 'cause it was so hard 'cause
you had to route everything
on your own.
So if you weren't familiar
with the map of the game,
you were just fucked.
- True.
- That was really fun
though. Because it's like,
it gives on a completely
different challenge to it
that it actually becomes like
really entertaining and fun.
- So are all new Pokemon games,
just this easy, unless you--
- They all hold your hand,
- artificially add
difficulty to your own run.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- I'd say ever since
Black and White or X and Y
is where it's really started
to like hold your hand.
- I understand gamers now.
(laughs)
I thought you guys were being babies
complaining about this stuff.
- No. It actually holds
your hand now it's like,
especially if you've played Pokemon
ever since the beginning.
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah. I go from that.
Which is to like, if you catch a Pokemon,
you need to commit to leveling it up.
- Oh. Dude. Like kids, if
I wanna give a kid today
who grew up on like sword and shield.
Or like the new remains give
them like the original blue
or like red and be like play
this game and just watch them
have a mental breakdown
of how difficult it is
compared to what they get today.
- Did you see the, what was it called.
I totally forgot now. Sorry.
- Ah, great.
(laughs)
No. Cause I remember
as a kid, I don't know,
some things just felt rewarding
that I don't feel rewarded
with this game. For example,
when you level up your Pokemon,
every Pokemon just
levels up automatically.
It's like an auto leveler.
- It was the Pokemon
Let's Go EV and Pikachu.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They gave your starter
Pokemon like increased stance.
The EV or Pikachu and
it had its special move.
It just one shot everything.
So they gave you the starter
that could just one shot.
- Now, the most bullshit part about EV,
I've really enjoyed EV to be fair,
but the most part about EV
was I did an EV only run
on stream ones because it's just so easy.
But in some of the Pokemons, you go to,
there's just this dude. Who's like,
I can teach your EV any move of any type.
- Oh my God.
- For free. Which one would you like?
It's like fire move.
And they're like really
powerful moves as well.
So it's like, what's the catch?
And it's like, no catch
it's because you talk to me,
it's like, Oh good. And I
think I did the EV only run
like four hours.
It was like one of the easiest games ever.
I only did it because I like EV.
- Was it after Pokemon Ruby
that everything started
to just get easy.
- I think the original Diamond and Pearl
was still like in that
same difficulty range.
I think, I reckon it was
around like X and Y six gen
where they introduced the
whole experience sharing
and the really holding your hand element
'cause Sun and Moon was
just so ridiculously easy.
And the same was Sword and Shield as well.
And then every other remake since then,
it's just been like baby mode.
- I remember when I
was a kid in the games,
this is like boomer. I
remember I was back in my day,
every game was just impossible.
But now we've gone too far.
- I remember crying, trying
to beat the first stage
of Mega Man 2.
I ride a game one Game Boy.
It was damnations 101, hardest
game ever played in my life.
- The Disney games like Game
Boy advance was so hard.
- Not even Game Boy
advance, like Game Boy.
- Oh game boy game.
- This shit was impossible.
I don't even know what the I was doing.
This is how games were back
then. Like I didn't even,
didn't even tell you the objective.
You just have to go around and figure out.
You know what kills you? I
don't know what is going on.
I don't even remember.
I didn't receive quality
feel once in that game,
I was just going around this thing.
It was like a construction site.
And I was one of the dogs
and I was like, what is this?
And I remember like
accordions were killing me.
what is this game? I
just don't understand.
Back then they used to just put you in--
- Was it one of those
unlicensed, Disney games or?
- No, no. It was an actual license.
- Oh my God.
- This is back when licensed
games were just put a platform
and just make it impossible.
- Yeah, it was back then where I was like,
take the IP, put it
into the Mario universe.
Change the design a little
bit. You have a game.
So that's what the Mick Mouse game was.
The one that I scammed
to my friend, basically.
It was like Stu it was basically
just a Mario platformer,
but it was stupidly hard.
- I should remember I
had this like PS 1 game
and it was a Shrek game.
It was a Shrek picnic game or something.
And I'm sure Shrek enthusiast
can inform me about this game.
I remember the whole point
of this game was to like,
you were assembling, I
could be describing this
completely correctly.
Like the parts to your picnic.
And you had to go and
like beat bosses and shit,
but like nothing worked
in the game, I remembered.
- I have to look this up.
- Okay. Can we give Shrek--
- It doesn't sound like a real game.
- Shrek a PS 1 games.
- Okay.
- Google it right there.
- Let's go Shrek.
- I just remember it's like
a FIFA Dream this game,
the polygons were so--
- A Shrek Treasure Hunt.
- That's it, That's it. This game.
I remember I played this game.
- Oh my God.
- There was like one
polygon in this whole game.
- That looks like asked, what is that?
What is that?
(laughs)
- I wanna, what is it?
There's three. I actually
has good ratings.
It's 78% like this video game.
What is it?
What's the synopsis?
Could we read the synopsis at this case?
- Shrek Treasure Hunt.
- Gameplay. Oh, plot.
As Shrek is preparing a picnic with Fiona,
the three blind Mike, steal,
all the picnic equipment,
such as foods and drinks.
So Shrek must go on an
adventure doing mini games
to get the items back
before Fiona arrives.
But I remember it was like
a bunch of mini games.
And these mini games,
just were all broken,
they didn't work.
- I love games with these kinds of plots
because you can just
imagine it just being like,
Fiona have to go get--
- I remember the camera was unusable
and it kept breaking my PS one.
And then eventually it just broke.
And I was so close to
the end of this game.
I was distraught.
- What's the last picnic item?
- I couldn't believe it.
I remember you have to go to
like some castle or something
to fight these mice or
some nonsense like that.
And I was just, I so angry
that I couldn't finish it.
- I have to find that and play it.
- You gotta play it, bro.
It sounds amazing. It's a great game.
You just stream it.
- I guess I should. Maybe I'll
stream it if you want me to.
- I wanna see it.
- I actually have a game
recommendation though,
that I found,
It is a JLBG though. It
is called 13 Sentinels.
- I think--
- I've heard of that.
- Have you heard of that?
So I found this by like complete accident.
'Cause I'm just like trying to
look through my game library
of like games. That sound interesting.
And I just kind of downloaded it on a whim
'cause I'm just like
anime game. Brilliant.
- It's not Pokemon anymore.
I say that Pokemon's an anime game.
- It's not typically.
- But yeah, I download it
and it is got a really
interesting concept.
So how I can best describe this.
It's like if you take Bokurano
and mix that with Steins;Gate.
So the reason it's called 13 sentinels
is because you have, basically
you have 13 main characters.
And so the way this story
unfolds is that you are able to
select a perspective of
part of this main character.
And the basis of this is at
some point in the future,
Kaiju come along and try
to destroy the world.
And so these 13 kids
have to save the world
from this Kajiu attack.
But I think they fail or something.
So time travel exists.
So you're watching, you're
playing this perspective,
this game from like 13
different perspectives.
And these perspectives jump
between timelines and universes,
depending on who you choose and
whose perspective you're on.
And you think this will
be a complete mess.
Like how can you tell a coherent
story when you can choose
between 30 different perspectives?
Well, how the game works is
that you can only progress
to a certain amount of point
in one person's per perspective
before you have to play
another person's perspective.
So one person's story route
is unlocked by playing
a certain part of another
person's story route.
So the way you get delivered,
the story is like little by
little and you get to piece
together what has happened
between this entire timeline.
It's actually like insane.
- That sounds cool.
- I remember my Twitch chat,
telling me all about it
being like, you'd love this game.
- Does it have good ratings?
- It does have good ratings.
That's kind of why I--
- Aegis Rim 13 Sentinels.
- 13 Sentinels: Aegis Rim.
- Oh, it's an Atlas game. Of
course. That's why it's good.
Of course.
- 94% Percent.
- So the gameplay is kind of
like a turn base strategy.
It's the best way I can describe is like--
- It looks gorgeous.
- That looks cute.
- It looks really cute.
- Yeah. It is a very
Atlas game, I realized,
'cause it's basically a
mix between a visual novel,
but with gameplay elements
to break up the story
of that visual novel.
- Switch versions coming
out in April this year.
- Ooh. Okay. But I highly recommend that.
That was just something
I played on the whim
because like I said, I give
everything like two hours
or something to try and grab me.
And this one like grabbed me immediately.
It has a very original storytelling method
and I'm about halfway through.
And like they use like some
of the twists and turns
I've seen in the story are insane.
- Atlas, don't miss man.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- You really don't miss.
- Yeah.
- Except that new Catherine
game, that was shit.
- I know more about the
memes of the Catherine game,
than actual people that have
played the Catherine game.
- I played the new Catherine
game and it was not that good.
- 'Cause it's weird. 'Cause
like a lot of this games just,
I hear more about the Japanese
side talking about it,
but like I hardly ever hear
anyone in the Western hemisphere
talking about it unless it's persona.
That's 'cause that's basically--
- I know Western hemisphere.
- Or the Western.
- The Western world.
- Western. I don't know why
I said hemisphere there.
- Is Japan in the Western hemisphere?
- Technically, anywhere
can be western hemisphere.
Depending on where you want.
- I Kinda realize that.
- I feel it's because in the
west it's a very core fan base
for Atlas games.
Because they are like
the JRPG players, J RPG.
- I know people who are like,
anime game, no thank you.
- Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
They take long--
- Thank you. Rightfully so.
- Yeah. They take one, look
at the visuals or the concept
and they're just like,
Nope, I'd rather play bang, bang, bang.
- Like this man for instance.
- I understand. There's a
certain kind of expectation
that comes with anime
games. That in my experience
is always the same.
You always get that same feeling.
Even if the stories are different,
the game plays different,
something about it just always
comes off as the same in
my mind. I don't know why.
- I don't fault people that
are thinking that though.
- That's what I like about it.
- That's consistency.
- I don't fault people
for thinking that though,
because that's exactly how I
feel with a lot of FBS games.
Where it's like, the concept is different,
but at the end of the day,
it's still bang, bang, bang.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It's fine.
- RPGs for me.
- Well like even like Western driven
story driven games as well.
It's just like, I don't know.
I guess it's a same reason why
I'm into anime versus movies
and TV shows where, I will
always watch a movie and TV show,
but those aren't the core
pieces of entertainment
that I like. For example, I
remember playing The Last of Us
and it's a great game,
but I just have like zero
emotional attachment to it.
I play it and I can
like objectively view--
- Is it because they are not anime?
- I guess I don't know.
- If they were more anime,
you'd be like, I care.
- I don't know why it was just
it's the way Western
storytelling works is that
it's got different tropes
and different method
of storytelling. But I don't
know of why I gravitate more
to like the anime style of storytelling
because I do think they
do have a different style.
- Definitely, definitely.
- Most different cultures.
- Yeah. Different cultures
and everything like that.
And the way Joel and Ellie
were written as characters
were great.
They were great characters.
I just didn't emotionally
attach myself to either
of those characters,
even though I could tell that
they were great characters.
- Why do you emotionally
touch yourself more
to anime characters then?
- 'Cause he's a whim.
- Well, there's gonna be a reason.
What about the way that
they did do their characters
is more appealing.
- I think it's because
they're unrealistic.
- I was gonna say, 'cause
that's what bothers me.
- I like the fact that
with anime characters
there's like a clear distinction
between reality and fantasy.
And I like having that
easy separation in my mind
where you can have great
really well written anime
characters that are still
clearly like really unrealistic.
Like just take any
Cinderella, for example,
you can have great written Cinderella,
but at the end of the day,
if you meet a real real life Cinderella,
you're just gonna think
that they're a bitch.
And why are they doing
domestic violence on their farm
or whatever, right.
- Do you think that the
authors who are writing these
are intentionally making
unrealistic characters
or they're intending
to do real characters,
but it just comes off
as unrealistic to us.
- I think it's all based on just
not only the cultural understanding
and norm of that author,
but it's also the fact
that a lot of these authors
are also hashing off
other Japanese creations
and other Japanese characters. Right.
So I don't really know of many
or any like Japanese author
who takes direct influence
from like Western stuff,
for instance.
Like the only one I can
think of is like Iraqi.
Which is why his
characters are so different
compared to the traditional norm,
like manga animated,
character style of character.
Not just visually, but
also as a characteristic
of that particular person.
- Why is like so many
animes set in high school?
Why is that like, is
that a cultural thing?
- Yeah. It's a cultural thing.
- Why, why so?
- It's because it's, for a lot of people,
like high school is kind of
seen as like this basically
like golden time.
- It's depressing.
- It's like for a lot of
people, high school is like,
the whole thing of like in
the west of like high school
is usually movies that are
based in high school in the west
are based off bad memories.
Being like, oh man, my high
school sucked, blah, blah, blah.
There were all these people,
the jocks, the bullies,
blah, blah, blah.
That's the norm in the west, in Japan,
it's glorified because to a lot of people,
high school was really fun time
with friends they'll never get back
and because it's also the
last years of that person
being young and free.
- I mean, I liked high
school, but I wouldn't say--
- I liked high school.
- How my life.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I think as well, in terms
of like a storytelling,
like standpoint as well, I
feel like kids in high school
or kids going through
puberty is just already
a really interesting character dynamic.
You can get characters to
get away with a lot of shit
just because they're in puberty.
- Yeah. But I feel like
there are so many shows
and so many anime where
you look at the characters
and they could be in any setting.
'Cause some of the shit
that these high schoolers
go through, they go
through two world wars.
They're like fighting
Avengers level threats
when they've reached the 13 years old.
- That's totally not a
well written character.
- That's not clearly just
an author of being like,
I like high school settings.
- Let's put them in a high school,
but don't actually take full
advantage of it, unfortunately.
But there's a lot of authors
that take full advantage
of the high school characters
and that whole setting
and actually work it into
their characters and story.
Mind you, that's the
minority. In my opinion,
a lot of them are just like
high school, realistic,
relatable with audience. Am I right?
- Yeah.
- Let's throw them in there.
- I watched Aggretsuko the
new season. That was good.
That was very refreshing.
Depressing is your always.
- Depressing is far. Yes.
- Which is great to see.
'Cause it's like one of
the only anime out there
that will actually like
commentate on adult life in Japan
and be realistic about it.
But it also says a lot when it,
no one knows about in Japan.
- Yeah.
- Is that true?
- It is absolutely unknown in Japan.
- Oh. Okay.
- Like it is not popular at all.
Probably because it's too real.
- It's been in Japan.
- It's literal real in Japan.
- Very Japanese things in it as well.
It's so Japanese, but
it's such a good take
on the Japanese work life.
- Yeah. It's awesome.
- How awful is.
- 'Cause it's ironic that this is coming
from the same company
that made Hello Kitty.
- Just to put it into perspective,
how deep they're going.
So in Japan they have a thing
called say shine, right.
Which is like an employee for life.
You can never fire this employee.
They have to do something
like really fucked.
- Well they have to leave
on their own accord.
- But like even the only
way they can get fired
is if they actually do
something like illegal.
- The only way they
can leave the company--
- You cannot be fired.
- Is by going to jail.
You could literally do the
shittiest job on earth.
Like you could like not turn
up and you cannot be fired.
So in Japan obviously,
'cause they decided--
- Talk about job security.
So obviously if you told that to anyone
in any Western country, they'd be like,
I don't think that sounds like a good idea
because it's not, let's just be honest.
Obviously job security
is good and that's good.
But it's a terrible idea for any business,
You need to be able to
get rid of employees.
But obviously in the west it's a little,
especially in some places
they're a little too happy
to fire employees.
So here has to be a balance.
- It's a balance,
There's a whole arc or like
story in the new season.
I won't spoil who it is or what it is,
but there's a character who,
because they can't fire him,
they just relocate him to some shit hole
and don't give him any work.
And they basically just like
morally make him want to quit.
And they're , and it's a whole
thing and it's really dark.
- That's the only way
that SA Shane can quit.
- Yeah. So that--
- Basically just pressure them.
- They bully you.
- They bully you to quitting.
So there's a whole thing where
they just make him fuck off
and like make him, you know,
cause obviously people are,
people wanna be valued when they do work.
And if you are just not doing anything,
you're gonna be like, why am I here?
Obviously if I was there,
I'd be like, fantastic.
I can catch up--
- Fantastic. Let's just play Apex.
- That's why it works in Japan.
It doesn't, I'm like you telling me,
I can just do whatever I want
and you're gonna give me the salary.
- What's the latest,
the greatest ski season.
- See you. I'm like,
Thanks for the paycheck.
This is why I'm never
gonna be hired full time.
Say Shannon.
No I've said that? This is bad.
Maybe that's for the better.
- Yeah. True. True.
- But yeah, they go to
some really dark stuff.
It's a shame that it's not being Japan.
I feel like a kid make
waves. Maybe it's too real.
- I think it is.
I think it's just purely the
fact that a Japanese person
will look at that and be like,
I don't want to see this because
it's just gonna remind me
of reality. And so a
lot of Japanese people,
that's not the reason
why they watch anime.
- That was a really one dark
bit. I mean I think sure.
You can remember it in
the new season. Right?
I spoil it. I won't say who it is.
I'll just say what happens.
- Oh no, no. I know what
you're talking about.
Maybe we shouldn't.
- You can't say that?
- No.
- Really? Is it that bad?
- It's a bit of a twist.
- All right, all right.
Haven't watched the--
- It's pretty bad.
- Just watch the whole
season. It's amazing.
- Honestly, regrets
carries is like killing it.
- I've had mixed reviews about
the fourth season, actually.
Some people have said that it feels like
it's said everything
it's needed to say now.
And it's like they're trying
a lot to bring something new
on the table.
- First five episodes, really good.
Last first episodes, boring.
Like completely unnecessary.
I did not like it.
That's how I felt this. Right.
I felt like they had a good
thing going and then they just--
- It definitely, it
fizzles out at the end.
- It's still a salt season though.
- I also watched all of Mushoku Tensei.
- Ooh. Look at you watching anime.
- I said I was gonna all of it.
All of it. One entered.
- Round of applause.
- Thank you.
After, I said I would
and everyone was like,
Connor's not gonna watch it.
And then there was a bunch
of comments that are like,
I hope Connor doesn't watch it.
'Cause I know he is gonna hate it.
- Did you hate it?
- No.
- Wow.
- I liked it.
- I liked it. I thought
it was good, honestly.
Yeah, it was really good.
I can see why people
think I would hate it.
Because the first episode
I was like, all right.
We champ, all right.
I mean, listen, listen,
the way it starts is weird.
'Cause he gets Isekai as you do.
'Cause it's the first Isekai.
That's all I knew about it.
Was, it was the only thing
I knew about the show
is that it was the first--
- I feel like whenever Connor hears Isekai
flashbacks of me talking like in--
- Basically, basically.
And so I went into this with an open mind.
I didn't read any reviews.
I didn't watch any videos.
I don't know anything
about Mushoku Tensei.
All know is that everyone hypes it out.
I was like, okay, I'll watch it.
Be me right, first
episode, Mushoku Tensei.
And he gets Isekai as a toddler.
This thing he does is
starts like admiring,
like the woman's tits.
And I'm like, oh this is the
show that everyone's hyping up.
This is it, this, this is it.
- He doesn't, he didn't
just admire the tits.
He like makes a shrine out
of like one of their panties.
- Yeah. So the whole,
first like two episodes
was just him being like an imbecile.
- I completely forgot about how --
- That was the one episode
I have erased from my mind.
- He's like an imbecile, And I was like,
are we seriously just gonna watch a guy,
another show where an
indocile just gets rewarded
with a massive cock in the new universe,
bestowed confidence, magical
power is the most op guy.
And never has to overcome
the fact that he has really
unhealthy views towards
women and sex and everything.
But this one was good,
'cause I felt like they,
he actually at least somewhat
learned that, Hey maybe,
maybe the way I viewed
women was kind of fucked up
in the past.
And I was like, it can
be done. Anime can do it.
- Not only was this the first Isekai,
but it was the first self realized insult.
- On top of that it was a good show.
And I was like, this is
great. This is fantastic.
Because not only was the
world building amazing.
I was really like into the world.
I loved all the characters,
even the parents
who they easily could have just been like,
oh it's just parents.
- Yeah. I was really surprised.
- They built everything up.
- I was really surprised when the parents
were just characters. Cause
normally you see anime parents
are just like half the time.
They're not even there.
And I remember watching.
- And when they are there,
you can't see their eyes.
- I was remember watching
because I'm so used to isekai
speed running this.
Which he gets transported,
starts like getting the girl,
starts beating up the dudes.
I'm five episodes into Mushoku Tensei.
I'm like, He's still with the parents?
What's what's going on.
And then I realized, wait a minute,
I'm actually getting invested
in the family dynamic
and the family story and stuff like that.
- It really is like the
slow cooker of isekai
where everything else is
just like a microwave.
- Can, I spoil one minor plot point.
It's not a big deal. It's
really not your bunch spoil--
- Spoiler warning.
The moment I knew this show
was built different really?
Was sitting there watching
episode six or seven.
It just starts. And the
first thing that happens
is it's like normal family life
is like, the husband has cheated
on the wife with the maid.
And she's pregnant.
I'm like what the fuck is this show doing?
What the fuck is going on?
And there was like a
whole point where he like
our 10 year old protagonist was diffusing,
this Jerry Springer episode.
I'm like, what is happening in the show?
Is this an isekai or
Jerry Springer's like,
you are not the parent. And I
said, yeah, what's going on?
Like I was so like, I was like.
I was like, is this good?
This is good. Right.
I think this is fun. This is great.
And then they actually get
into world building later on.
And it's amazing.
- Yeah. I mean, what I like
about it is that it does take
that time to like build up shit
with all this, Jerry Springer,
just to say like, Hey, dad's
kind of an ass hole as well.
He can do bad things.
He ain't the perfect human being.
And then like, it helps it just like,
it all plays part into
like his journey, I guess.
And I think the biggest
down point was you finish
the first season. You're like
this story hasn't even begun.
- I thought I missed an episode
or something when it ended,
I was looking. 'Cause I
thought, oh my episode 11,
it must be 12. 'Cause
it ended so abruptly.
I was like, oh, where's the episode 12?
And then I was start running
the new season I was sucked
I mean that I had one less episode.
- You wanna hear on me?
I've only seen first season.
- Second season's amazing.
The second season is really good.
- Second season is where you
get so much of the payoff?
Of what was like the world
building that's built up
in the first season.
I would be quite annoyed if I watched it
and season 2 wasn't out. 'Cause
I think I feel blue ball.
But it was a great show.
Like again, I wanna,
I can't give credit enough,
but the fact that they
actually like just--
- Did something different?
- did something different and it worked.
And the fact that this
is the first Isekai.
Which makes me like really concerned.
- Why did they not take the
good parts of this show?
What I can't understand is
how they take this concept
of the main guy being an indocile.
That's what he is. Right.
I'm just gonna keep saying it.
I absolutely hate these
characters as well.
Because what what's up.
- [Director] Correction.
Technically the light novels
were like ReZero and like--
- Yeah, I was okay.
Yeah. I was going to
correct him afterwards.
So it's not the first isekai,
but it's one of the most prominent isekais
that popularized--
- The genre.
- A Lot of the genre. Yeah.
Okay, so let's say this is
like one of the first big ones,
if everyone is trying to take from this,
why do they take all the worst aspects?
Because Isekai to me
is like I said earlier,
it's just dudes who don't
have to ever address
the fact that they were
shitty in the life before
and they just get a free Doover
where they get everything done for them.
- Yeah. I mean it's weird seeing,
because it was weird
watching this after watching
so many Isekai that have
been inspired by this show,
because with most genres you
have like the progenitor,
the thing that popularized
a lot of the tropes,
and by the time you watch it--
- It's a nice word, progenitor.
- Progenitor.
- Doesn't even sound any real word.
- Would you pull that one out, Garnt?
- By the time you watch that one,
you've already seen all the tropes before.
So you're like, well,
this just feels dated now.
I don't get why everyone
hyped this thing up
in the first place, because
by the time you see it,
everyone's already done
all the tropes differently
and better. Right?
But with Mushoku Tensei,
it's like so many stories
just missed the point of why
the Isekai is the way it is.
why is it an Isekai in the first place?
Well, it's because he's
transported to another world
to give himself another
chance at life and people.
And a lot of stories took that as just,
oh, let's just put this
kind in a fancy world
and just disregard the fact
that he had a previous life,
that's just, there's so many subtle things
about Mushoku Tensei as a
story that I feel just got lost
over time.
In the different iterations
of isekai that came after.
That's not to say there's
not other isekai shows
that come after it.
That haven't been good.
But like, it seems like--
- Yeah. There are a dime dozen.
- Like the fact that he
had to, sorry, go George
- Yeah. It just seems like
so many stories just took
the surface level elements of this story
without really thinking about
why those elements were there
in the first place.
- This is like, maybe Rezi
did this a little bit,
but not to the same extent, but like,
this is the only other
Isekai guy that I've watched.
I'm sure there are
others that have done it
where he actually had to deal
with the trauma and fears
that he had in his past life
carried over into this one.
'Cause like, let's say you
come into this new life.
And you were scared of snakes.
You're not gonna be magically,
not scared of snakes.
You've got the same brain.
He's still scared of going outside.
And I liked that they
had to deal with that.
Like I love that he had to
work through all of his issues.
Of course I wanted the plot
to go ahead and I wanted him
to become op and kill everything
and become the giga chat.
But I also wanted to see
him actually have to work
through the shit.
- You wanted it to be
believable when it happens.
- Yeah.
- And it's so much better
payoff when you get to see that.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- 'Cause like I was also at
the point when I was like,
when's the, I'm enjoying this,
but when's the plot gonna happen?
And then I've slowly come to realize that
whenever an episode is
labeled turning point,
I'm just like pack like
put your seatbelts on boys
because some shit is gonna go down.
And I've heard from
like light novel readers
that they're just like,
oh, just wait till you get
to turning point 4 or 5 or something.
I'm like, there's turning
point 5? What is going on?
Basically just a drift course.
- It's like, I love shows that
are confident in their world.
And they don't need the
characters to be the world.
It's they are so comfortable.
- The world lives independently
from the characters.
- It's like, we just happen to
be following some characters
in this world. That's interesting.
We could follow any of the characters
and you still have a great time.
I honestly I'll give
it like a 9/10 so far.
- I feel like a proud father.
- I love it. I love it.
It's a good show. Honestly, it's so good.
Like if you're like me and
you're so done with isekai,
I'd give this one a shot.
It is genuinely worth it.
- When's this episode coming out?
- [Director] This one?
- Yeah.
- Hold on.
- Probably the end of the month. Right?
End of the month.
- End of the month. February.
- [Director] I think
first week of February.
- First week of February.
- Wow. What's up?
- The first week of February. Yes.
- That's why I give Mushoku
Tensei anime of the year.
(all laugh)
I just didn't wanna spoil that.
- No, I mean, I understand.
I feel like, I haven't watched odd taxi
or anything like that yet,
but I mean, I was watching
it and I'm like, God,
they're just doing everything right.
I don't know. I can't
complain about anything.
- I mean, the only thing I
put it above that was "Arcane"
as the best show of this year,
it's been zero days literally.
- Okay. Okay.
- "Arcane" movie is better.
"Arcane" is pretty good though.
- Arcane is pretty damn good.
But yeah, I mean that's
yeah. I'm so fucking happy.
I'm I'm so happy that--
- It's like, when your
son finally starts getting
an interests in sports
like football or like--
- Is this what gratification feels like?
- You're gappy. I like,
what if I came in there
guns blazing and shit. Can't say--
- I honestly thought you
wouldn't like it. 'Cause--
- Why do you think that?
- Because a lot of the
characters, like I said before,
they are well written characters,
but a lot of them are
like very trophy, very--
- There are some, there are some.
- Very trophy, but I still think
they're well written characters,
but I just thought you'd look at that.
And you'd just be like, not a
fucking Cray with red hair--
- I mean, she was annoying.
Don't get me wrong.
She's was probably my
least favorite character.
Out of all the characters.
I felt like--
- It is hard to look
past the trops sometimes.
Didn't really like the main
character much. Actually.
- I didn't really like him as well.
Well, I kind of liked.
- But I understand why he's not,
I don't think his intention
was to make him likable
from an audience perspective.
- I actually think who's the character,
the character I liked the
most actually was the spur.
I love the spur, the green
name, the green head guy.
- Ruijerd.
He was sick.
Like you said, I like the languages
that they actually spoke languages.
- I know. Right.
- That was cool.
That was really refreshing
for once where you're like,
are they speaking a foreign language?
'Cause they're always
just speaking Japanese.
- Finally.
- 'Cause I remember
when they were speaking,
I'm just like, when are they
gonna switch to Japanese?
It's just like world building, man.
Its just make sure like
invest in this place.
And then it pays off when
he learns how to speak
these languages. Like, oh my God.
- Oh my God, this is what
is like to learn a language.
Oh my God. Speak it in a reasonable bound.
- It's like the real world.
Holy shit. Who would've
thought I have so much
of an appreciation for that.
Knowing what he went through
to learn that language.
- This is one of those shows
where I'm actually glad
it's a light novel before
it's an anime or anything.
'Cause I think that it's
really gonna benefit
from being in like a long form written.
- Yeah. So you can cash out the details.
- They can really get like the world set.
'Cause sometimes when shows come this big,
they kind of get to the point
where like, oh we gotta,
we gotta get the seasons out, come up.
It's the hot shit. Come on.
We gotta finish it. So I'm
hoping that doesn't happen.
I hope the anime 'cause I'm not
gonna read the light levels.
'Cause the anime's so
good. And why would I?
- Yeah. I mean like the anime's so good.
The production values were like insane.
Like some of the animation--
- Season 2, the jump
from season one to two
was definitely noticeable.
I noticed that it got better.
Like it looked a lot crisper.
- I mean it's just an all
around amazing production.
- Watch sugar.
- I'll definitely have to watch season 2.
- I've been talking about it for ever.
And I'm like, so happy right now.
I'm happy. I'm happy.
You know what Connor?
Maybe I'll play Apex.
- When are you gonna play Apex?
Maybe I'll play Wins or Apex dream corner.
- How many hours--
- You are like that dad that's like, son,
- Well, how many.
- I'll do something you like this time?
- Count the exact run
time of Mushoku Tensei
that's how many hours you play actually,
that seems fair. That seems fair.
- When this episode ends
I'll play Apex with you.
- There we go. There we go.
There we go. Content.
- The Titan has fallen.
- 'Cause I've got a
second channel now guys
and we we've all got a second
channel that we upload to.
The Garnt channel is gonna
turn to an Apex channel.
I uploaded every other day
on that channel in January.
- Every other day.
- How did you have that much content?
- Stream.
- Backlog. I have a
backlog as well on there.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah. 'Cause I took all of January off.
I didn't upload any videos
in January. Or maybe one.
I don't know. 'Cause this is
before the end of January.
- I'm just like, how are you saying this?
When, when we we're right
in January now I have to--
- All my plans always go
correctly without any backfire.
- Yeah, definitely.
This might be a enthusiasm
moment, but yeah.
So yeah, I took a month off
and it's pretty chill ready?
Weird waking up and not
thinking about YouTube videos.
Kinda just thinking like,
oh my stream leader.
I might play some games, go gym.
- Live a life.
- Yeah. Live a fucking life.
Have a life for once.
- Yeah, because I noticed
that you haven't, I mean,
you two haven't really thought
so much about your upload
schedule, which you did before.
Is that really.
- Just for this month?
- Well, your main channel was least.
- Yeah.
- I just wanna take a month off
and get some stuff in order.
I've got a bunch of
videos that really are big
that I need to finish.
And I know that if I'm
trying to do them weekly,
it'll be a mess. So I just wanna get them.
I've got like three big videos
in the works at the moment.
So I'm trying to get them all done.
And then hopefully February
will be a nice roll in,
probably gonna do a bunch
of more back to normal.
- Do you feel like after
you do the big projects
that you're just gonna
go back to your normal
upload schedule or are
you gonna focus more
on streaming now?
- Maybe I'll miss a week here
and there not feel too guilty
about it. I'm probably
try and do three a month.
I think that'll be my soft target.
- Three a month.
- Yeah. I'll probably try and
do once a week, but we'll see.
- That's just above my
upload schedule actually.
- Well, I feel like if I miss
a week, it's not a big deal.
I'm like now right on my phone, I check,
I check the other day. 'Cause I was like,
I haven't uploaded in
like two and a half weeks.
I wonder if anyone's saying anything?
No, no, no one's commented anything.
- No, of course not.
- So clearly nobody
misses that'd be right.
- That's exactly what I
realized when I realized, oh,
I don't have to do an anime
of year video on the new year.
And I could just wait a few
weeks and people were just like,
great. I'll still watch your content.
- Who would've thought
that the only ones who care
about our timetable is us.
And no one else.
- I mean, I feel like when you do weekly,
it just posture a bit
more. You do do good.
- Of course, but you also, I
feel it also limits yourself
to what you could actually be doing.
So which is why like this year for me,
I'm definitely gonna like slow
it down and just like really
focus on like making each
video as big as possible.
And then for everything
else, I got Trash Taste
and like my second channel
and stuff like that.
- It's whatever.
So what is the main channel anymore?
When Trash Taste is--
- This is the main channel now .
- That be real, this is
the main channel now.
- This is where the big ideas are going.
- This is where it's all going.
- We're doing more specials this year.
We're gonna stream every week.
You heard here first.
- Well this February.
- I hope this doesn't
become Poliage thing.
- Yeah. I read every
I'm saying it publicly.
- Obviously there will be breaks.
- Of course. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
But yeah, I think, I think
for all of us, like our,
for this year, definitely Trash Taste
is slowly be coming
more over the priority.
I think when it comes to
just like making cool shit.
- Yeah. 'Cause we enjoy
it, 'cause we enjoy it.
And who knew that just having
a job of your best mates
is fun.
- Pretty chill.
- God forbid.
- Have a carry every week. That's life.
- Speaking of watching anime,
I know a bunch of people who
have also been watching anime
very publicly. It's
probably very old news.
By the time this episode gets released.
- It was the dumbest shit of 2022 so far.
- 2022 has just begun.
We're already taking an L.
- But yeah, basically at
the time of recording,
Pokemon has been banned
for watching Avatar,
The Last Air Bender
and also Disguised Toast
has also been banned
for watching Death Notes.
I believe on their twist streams.
To their tens of thousands of viewers.
And by the time this gets released,
maybe more people will
be banned. Maybe not.
I don't know. But it's
definitely sparked a discussion
about copyright and DMCA.
- I think people online
are calling it the TV meta,
which I couldn't fucking
believe was a real thing.
Polygon wrote this
article that was like, oh,
this guy starts, he was just
testing out the TV meta.
And I think my favorite comment, I saw,
I wanna quote retweet
It was, "Calling it the TV
meta is like shooting yourself
"in the head and calling it the gun meta."
- Lime wire wasn't Paris.
It was just engaging in the music meta.
- The TV meta strand is piratey.
- Pirating doesn't do that.
So dumb, it's so dumb.
- It's the dumbest argument.
- It's crazy. Like watching
stuff like the Totally Not Mark,
With like torrent.
Just like nuking his channel.
For like talking about one piece.
- Yeah. For not even breaking DMCA.
- And then the Twitch
streams just go and watch
the entirety of Hunter Hunter.
- Yeah. Because I remember
like when I first heard
about this, I thought it was,
I thought it was actually
just like a joke.
I thought it as like a parody article,
I'm just like, where's the onion article?
And then I log onto Twitch.
And then I see one of
like the biggest streamers
on the, I'm just gonna, I saw
XQC streaming Hunter Hunter,
like in it like a hundred thousand people.
And I'm just like, I was
watching ,cause I was like,
is there a meme?
Like where's the meme come?
And then I, you realize,
oh they weren't joking. People
are actually doing this.
And then Connor informed me that Ludwig
had already made a video about it.
And I think what bothered
me was that people
were calling them out for
calling other people out
for being like, yeah. why
are you knocking on people
or something like that?
And I'm just like,
imagine you are like
broadcasting a football match
in a football stadium that you don't own
because that's what the
equivalent of it is. Right.
They're broadcasting this
to like 90,000 people.
And one guy like, "Is that allowed?"
And people are just actually
like, sh don't tell people
and it's just like, are you kidding me?
There's 90,000 people
watching this right now.
How could you snitch on someone
when there's 90,000 people
watching this one thing.
- It's so dumb.
And the fact that they're trying to argue
it's fair use or anything.
It's just so stupid.
- Yeah, the fair argument's ridiculous.
- I understand. Right.
'Cause a lot of the
viewers who watching this
probably enjoyed it.
They probably loved watching
SQC watch "Hunt Hunter".
- Yeah, of course.
- I'm sure everyone would
love to watch us watch "Jojo".
Unfortunately, we can't do that.
'Cause one we're not fucking
dumb. We don't watch shit.
- We'll literally be breaking the law.
- I did a watch along of Jojo on my stream
the previous season,
but I didn't show the
visuals. I didn't show audio.
I show a time stamp.
You can go to your Netflix
and we can watch along.
It's not as good. Of course it sucks.
'Cause you can't see it.
But it's against the law to do that.
And also we live in Japan.
We probably actually be
thrown in jail if we did that.
- Yeah. Oh yeah. No you will. You will.
- It's just like, what annoyed me the most
about it was again,
like it was people trying to be like,
it was very like tribal in a
sense where they were like,
you can't say my stream
is bad for doing it.
They were just watching
doesn't do any harm.
So what if they get banned?
It's like, yeah. But yeah,
because that streamer already
makes like 5 million a year.
Of course they don't give
a fuck if they get banned.
But like what about the guy,
there's other smaller
streamers who maybe enjoy
the freedom to the
current copyright system
where they can kind of, tow
the line a little bit safer.
Not watching stuff, but
maybe I can show YouTube,
- Maybe a clip. Yeah.
Remember you couldn't watch
YouTube on Twitter before.
You can now, even then
that's controversial.
Yeah. But I just feel like
it's selfish of like the bigger
creators who already are well established,
don't have to worry about or anything--
- And they can get away with it as well.
- They'll come back, they'll get banned,
they'll come back. They don't give a shit.
- If anything, them getting banned,
its just more publicity to them.
- Yeah. Because that's why, right.
It's like you can get banned
and you're a headlined
and people are like, oh
my God, you're banned,
how that's so crazy.
We'll come back and like
you'll get even more views
and you come back. It's like,
it's just, I don't know.
It just seems selfish to me.
- It is.
- And the fact that everyone's
trying to call it a meta
and play a joke with it and
stuff is really frustrating
when, we work in Japan.
We talk a lot with the anime companies
and try and work with them
and try and convince them
that YouTubers and
stuff aren't psychopaths
and can be trusted.
- I think that's what
bothered me the most.
Which is like, as someone
who does make content
that really does require fair
use and a strong argument
for fair use even I think
like sometimes I'm still like
touting the line sometimes
with how companies view my content.
Because it's such a new concept
that it's going to take time
to like convince big companies that,
Hey, please don't strike my stuff
because it is under fair use.
And when you have like like this,
and then on the other end of the spectrum,
you have people just
broadcasting, licensed TV shows,
movies, anime, whatever.
It's just, what's going to happen is that
it's just going to make it harder
for the 60, 70 year old
guy looking at new content
to be like, well I guess
everyone's just broadcasting
my shit. Right.
Well I guess I should
strike down everyone.
What it's the thing that's
gonna happen is that it's gonna
make it hard for big corporations
to tell the difference
between what is fair use and what isn't.
Because when there is people
who are abusing the system,
because this is an abuse of the system,
then it's just gonna be harder
for the guy who is actually
trying to stay within the system to prove
that he's actually
staying within the system.
- I feel there's just
so many like YouTubers
and Twist streams, just
content creators who are like
doing our best to like at
least try and like yeah,
as you were saying, like show
the Japanese corporations
being like, hey, fair use is a thing.
We're not using your stuff all the time
for malicious intent. We do it
because we genuinely love it.
We want people to know about it.
But we will follow the
rules that are laid out
as much as we can. But at the same time,
I scratch your back,
you scratch mine. like kind
of like forgive me sometimes.
But now with this whole TV meta,
if I feel all that effort
has just gone back to zero.
- Yeah. Especially on Twitch.
- If it works, if speculating of course.
But like obviously like
it could really damage.
- It's a matter of time.
I mean the music industry did
it with Twitch, eventually.
They were like, oh, shit yeah.
You shouldn't be shoot or
streaming music. It's not good.
And people are like, whatever,
testing out the music matter.
Because the other thing that bothered me
is that you can't really feign ignorance
because there is a precedence for this.
YouTubers have felt it for years
with their copyright system,
even Twitch streamers.
And I know a lot of Twitch
streamers complained a lot
when they had the DMCA
controversy with the music thing
that happened.
Where basically every piece
of music just got claimed
and you couldn't even play some games
because some of the music was copyrighted.
- Which was bound to happen anyway.
- Yeah. Which was bound to happen.
YouTube have been dealing
with that for years.
It's very entitled. And
the that's what it is.
It is entitlement.
A lot of the streamers
that were doing this,
just like, don't give a fuck.
'Cause why would they? They don't mind.
They get the headlines,
they get the views.
They already got paid.
They already have these
contracts with these companies.
- And they know they'll come back.
- Yeah. They know they'll come back.
'Cause they get special
treatment. - Exactly.
- Yeah. And then you have
like people on the other side
of the fence, people like
totally not mark, who like,
if you don't know a story
behind what happened
with Totally Not Mark, I
believe like TOE striked,
hundreds of his videos at once.
- Yeah, 150.
- Over like 150 videos at once.
Some of them not even, even like having
any copyrighted material on there.
Some of them were just like,
I believe his face or like
- Some of them were drawings
of dragon ball characters
that he drew.
- And so his channel
basically got completely,
like so many of these videos
got completely wiped away
and he was like fighting tooth and nail
to like try to get into
contact with Toe, to be like,
please Toe, bring my videos
out of copyright jail, please.
This is fair use.
And I believe that even
now it's not been sorted.
I believe now he is--
- He basically just like gave up.
- Yeah, I believe he just gave up.
- Which is so hard brain.
'Cause I think like a third of
his channel just disappeared.
- Yeah, exactly.
And that's like--
- It's like, could you imagine that
it's just like years of work just gone.
- And that, to me, it's
just like, well it's like,
there's this guy fighting
tooth and now to try and prove
that his videos are fair use
and his videos do deserve
to be in the platform.
- And they are fair use.
- To like a company that
doesn't know the difference
between fair use and not.
And then on the other
side of the spectrum,
you have other people who are
abusing the system to be like,
well, whatever the ban ham is coming down.
I can take like a two day
vacation, a month vacation,
whatever.
And the people who feel the repercussions
are the people who are like on
the load end of the tier list
with, let me rephrase that.
- Lower end of the spectrum.
- Lower end of the spectrum
of Twitch streamers.
The smaller content creators.
That's the word I was looking for,
the smaller content
creators, the smaller boys.
- A lot of these, the
bigger content creators,
I think highly often it just
kind of sad seeing them do this
and like some of them just not
caring. And I was just like,
this is just sad.
I also just think you
should be a good example.
Like why don't just like make stuff?
I don't know. Like--
- Because what's gonna happen
is the big streamers do it.
Then everyone goes, oh, if
the big streamer doing it,
I can do it too.
But of course they don't
realize those big streamers
if they get in trouble
or they'll get as a slap
on the wrist,
if the smaller creator does it,
they're probably perma banned.
- 'Cause I'm just like
to preface this, I don't,
this isn't like us trying to start drama
with any of the content
creators that did this
because a lot of the content
creators, I actually respect
as content creators.
It was like Connor said,
I was just a bit disappointed
that they didn't set
a better example because I know
that we are all content creators.
We know what's going on here.
We know what the
repercussions are going to be,
that what they could
be. So it's just like,
I couldn't understand why they
were poking the Hornets nest,
I guess.
- Some of them were doing it intentionally
trying to get banned as well.
Some of them admitted that,
that they wanted to be banned.
'Cause it's good for headlines as well.
If you're a bigger name
and you have more websites,
cause they're websites,
they're just dedicated
to literally just talking
about Twitch streamers.
And then post these articles,
they get them recommend to me
all the time on Google.
Just like, "You won't
believe what Ludwig said."
and it'll be like, Ludwig's
like, "I like jumping."
I hate these articles. They're so shit.
- Welcome to journalism.
- It's a little thing called
independent journalism.
- But it's like how have you
then at least take a click bait
and not even made it somewhat interesting
that's even more boring.
- Now, because, I think what
the other thing that made me
lose brain cells when I was
like scrolling on my Twitter
to see what the reaction was,
was the amount of people
who were calling out people
who were like, basically saying,
"Hey, maybe you shouldn't
stream or broadcast anime movies
"to like your audience, whatever."
And anyone who said that was
basically basically caught
out to being like for being
like a corporate boot licker
or something like that.
Or just like, why are you
defending the corporations?
And it's just like it turned the argument
into something completely different
because we all know DMCA
is like a decade old law
that is outdated for
how the internet works.
We're concentrators.
We know that there are so
many things that are broken
about the DMCA system. We know that,
but that's a separate issue
to what is going on here.
A system can be broken and
people can also abuse the system
at the same time.
They don't have to be mutually.
They don't have to be the same thing.
They can be mutually exclusive.
And just seeing people try to defend this,
just like kind of just
made me lose brain cells.
- It was weird. It was really weird
seeing how open everyone was like, yeah,
no, of course it's okay.
And I'm like, yeah, just 'cause you like,
it doesn't mean it's okay.
- And just because you can't
be bold to go to Google
and look it up yourself. It's like.
- Like obviously it would
be sick to watch anime
with 90,000 people live.
- Oh, it would be sick.
- I would love to do that.
- We can't, we're not allowed.
- Until I get up these like IP holders,
understand that it's okay.
And we're not saying this
shouldn't be the case.
You know what I would say that
if a company wants to be five heads,
they would allow people, they
would allow people to stream
all that old forgotten shows
and bring it to a new audience.
I think that would be a five head move.
But until people allow
it, it's still illegal.
You're still putting risk
on, in an entire platform
that you're gonna put the clamp down
for all the content
creators on that platform.
- It's like that Japanese
YouTuber who got to react
to all of attack on Titan
and like got promotion.
- He like uploaded all of him--
- Yeah. He had this deal
with Attack on Titan IP.
- It's crazy. How did he get that?
- And he was just like, oh yeah.
So you got a second channel.
It's got like a million subs.
Just put all of Attack on
Titan on it. You're allowed.
- Yeah. With him reacting.
- Yeah. I saw that.
- Was him reacting to it.
And it was completely legal.
- What's crazy to me is
that like the whole entire
YouTube community,
everyone on everyone online
hated reaction channels.
They came down so hard
on them in like 2015, 16.
And then like, why is it different now?
I don't understand.
- Now. Everyone's--
- What happened, is it 'cause it's live?
Is that the only difference?
Like I don't understand.
- The Twitch matter. The TV
matter, the react matter.
- The react matter.
- I guess what we've
learned is that it's bad.
It's a bad thing to do.
Unless your favorite
content creator is doing it,
then it's not.
- Yeah, exactly.
- All right. That's a
good message to end it on.
- That's a good message.
- I just want to go
throughout like all of history
and just start calling like
the most despicable acts
of human history. Just like a matter.
- I do the after Joe.
- All right. Well, if you guys, hey,
you guys wanna join the patron
medal? Look at these patrons.
- The 50 patron matter.
- They're limit testing the
Paton meta right now, guys,
if you wanna join them,
then maybe go to our patron
page on patreon.com/trashtaste
also falls on Twitter.
Send us a email in the Sub with
it and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
But yeah, God.
TV meta is now my least
favorite phrase of 2022.
- NFT, TV. Meta, what
about the NFT TV meta?
- What about the NFT meta?
- We're just going through
the blockchain meta right now.
- Ah. Gross.
- Anyway, you've been
watching Trash Taste.
This has been the Trash Taste meta.
- Join the patreon meta,
that's the new meta.
- The patreon meta.
That's the only good meta.
- And we'll see you
all next week. Bye bye.
(upbeat music)